Programming Throwdown, Episode 185 Workflow orchestrators. Take it away, Patrick. Welcome to another guaranteed to be fantastic episode. That's right, yeah, it's money back. I nailed it. We've been doing this too long. Okay. I'm going to try something a little different.
Programming Throwdown，第185期，工作流编排器。Patrick，开始吧。欢迎收听又一期保证精彩的节目。没错，确实，如果不精彩可以退款。我成功了。我们做这个节目太久了。好吧，我要尝试一些不同的东西。
I was thinking about this. I don't have a good formulation of it. So you can sort of help me. All right. But it's sort of been coming up in a number of things. And the sort of most obvious one is when people talk about venture capital, which is, you know, investors, mostly tech investors. And they invest in, you know, 100 companies. But really, they're expecting sort of tend to do really well.
我一直在思考这个问题。我还没有一个很好的表述方式，所以你可以帮帮我。好的。但这在很多事情中都有所体现。最明显的例子就是人们谈论风险投资时，也就是那些投资者，主要是科技投资者。他们投资了，你知道，100家公司。但实际上，他们只期望其中大约10家能做得非常好。
they're hoping the rest don't, you know, they just assume they basically go to zero, they kind of don't care, and then they hope, you know, one or two, 1,000 X or whatever and pay for the risk they take over the entire pool.
他们希望其余的，你知道，他们只是假设它们基本上会归零，他们不太在意，然后他们希望，你知道，有一两家能翻1000倍或者其他什么，来弥补他们在整个投资组合中所承担的风险。
And, you know, part of that is this sort of like asymmetric returns. And then I began thinking, it pops up in sort of other things. You know, people were talking, you know, most recently I was listening to someone talking about, about health recommendations,
你知道，这其中一部分就是这种所谓的不对称回报。然后我开始思考，它在其他事情中也会出现。你知道，人们在谈论，最近我听到有人在谈论关于健康建议的话题，
like how much protein should you consume? And people have this, you know, oh, maybe you did this much, maybe that much, maybe. And then we sort of said, you know, up to a certain point, it kind of, you know, is very, very important. And then past another point, you know, it's, you kind of get this like nonlinear relationship. And then I began to think about it. And they kind of said something that led me to thinking about it in terms of, in terms of work,
比如你应该摄入多少蛋白质？人们有这种，你知道，哦，也许你摄入这么多，也许那么多，也许。然后我们说，你知道，在达到某一点之前，它非常非常重要。然后超过某一点，你知道，你会得到这种非线性的关系。然后我开始思考它。他们说了一些话，引导我从工作的角度去思考它，
which is if you set a certain target goal for how much you learn, you know, in a given day or continual learning or, you know, how much output you want at work, I think. internally we have this, you know, sort of everything gets kind of normally distributed that maybe some days you're going to be a little bit above, some days a little bit below, some days, you know, very rarely a lot above, you know, very rarely a lot below. And in my head, at least, you know, I think we do this thing that pops up intuitively over and over again where things kind of clump together and become sort of normally. And we think that the returns there end up being, you know, kind of not super impactful, like they even out, basically, that the unders
那就是如果你为自己设定一个学习量的目标，你知道，在某一天或持续学习中，或者，你知道，你在工作中想要多少产出，我想。在内部我们有这种，你知道，一切都呈正态分布，也许有些日子你会稍微高一点，有些日子稍微低一点，有些日子，你知道，很少有高出很多，你知道，很少有低出很多。至少在我的脑海里，你知道，我认为我们一直在直觉上重复做这件事，事情会聚在一起并变得呈正态分布。我们认为那里的回报最终是，你知道，不是特别有影响力，就像它们基本上抵消了，那些不足
and the overs, overs, you know, are okay. But what I began to realize, and sorry, trying to bring it full circle, it's a little cloudy in my mind, but back to the VC thing, this health thing, that they were sort of saying, you kind of need to set your targets a little higher, because actually, depending on where you are on this sort of like return curve, right, that is not flat. it's not, you know, just one single slope that if you are at one of these inflection points or lower, then the good days can be sort of 10x and the bad days are, you know, negative some amount. And if you're really low, what ends up happening is those negative amounts are sort of larger than the big amounts and you can sort of lose ground or, you know, not move
和过剩，过剩，你知道，还可以。但我开始意识到，抱歉，试图把话题绕回来，我脑子里有点模糊，但回到风险投资这件事，这个健康问题，他们说的是，你需要把目标定得稍微高一点，因为实际上，取决于你在这种回报曲线上的位置，对吧，它不是平的。它不是，你知道，只是一个单一的斜率，如果你处于这些拐点或更低的位置，那么好日子可以是10倍，坏日子是，你知道，负的某个量。如果你真的很低，最终发生的情况是那些负的量比大的量要大，你可能会失去阵地，或者，你知道，没有向前
forward versus if you're higher up on the curve and you set your target, then even the low days, you know, you're still sort of moving forward. And so when I talk about like learning or output at work, if you, you know, sort of set your target as like my median is I get a little bit of good stuff done. And some days I get a lot. Some days I don't. Some days I make more work for myself by doing something stupid or saying something dumb at work, right? You kind of think about this as like evening out to like slow, small steps. But in reality, setting yourself up for at least some of those home runs. So setting yourself up. positionally but also just where your target is like in how you expose yourself it sort of drifts
移动，而如果你在曲线的更高位置，并且你设定了目标，那么即使是糟糕的日子，你知道，你仍然在向前移动。所以当我谈论学习或工作产出时，如果你，你知道，把你的目标设定为我的中位数是我完成了一些好的工作。有些日子我完成了很多。有些日子我没有。有些日子我通过做一些愚蠢的事情或在工作中说一些蠢话给自己制造了更多的工作，对吧？你倾向于认为这会抵消为缓慢、微小的进步。但实际上，为自己设定至少一些全垒打的目标。所以为自己设定位置，但也仅仅是你的目标在哪里，就像你如何让自己暴露在机会中，它会漂移
away sorry my analogy is breaking but like you sort of shift yourself into a position where you're you know you still have days that are below average but you're above average days give you this exposure opportunity for just outsized growth right you're taking those really really hard home runs at work you're you know going for just you know really stretch opportunities and thinking about this you know it's just an interesting thing i've been juggling with which is i think a lot of myself included a lot of the time I don't give myself this opportunity to have this sort of outperformance, this exposure, this VC 1000X, right? You know, we talk about investment. You do the boring. Everyone always says, just put all your money in the S&P 500 or the Russell
抱歉，我的类比有点崩了，但就像你把自己转移到一个位置，你知道，你仍然有低于平均水平的日子，但你高于平均水平的日子给了你这种获得超额增长的暴露机会，对吧？你在工作中进行那些非常非常艰难的全垒打，你在，你知道，追求那些真正，你知道，非常具有挑战性的机会，思考这个问题，你知道，这只是我一直在权衡的一件有趣的事情，我认为很多时候，包括我自己，我没有给自己这种获得这种超额表现、这种暴露、这种风险投资1000倍的机会，对吧？你知道，我们谈论投资。你做无聊的事情。每个人总是说，把所有的钱都投入到标普500或罗素
5,000, you know, just put all your money in there, this very average dot return. But maybe some amount of it, maybe some small amount, you got to take those like really big swings and you've got to limit it. But if it, you know, 1,000x, it could carry the whole portfolio. Yeah. So I can I can riff on this. I mean, so I don't know if I mentioned this in a past episode, but there's an awesome book from Nassim Nicholas Taleb, The Black Swan. Have you read The Black Swan? Yes. Yep. Yeah. So, yeah, I'm a big proponent that there are black swans and there are white swans. In other words, like, there are... Wait, is white swan the opposite of Black Swan? Well, White Swans, okay, first of all, white swam is a term I literally just made up five seconds ago. But the white swans, but the white swans is the term, but the white swans. I would define it as like, you know, it's an unexpectedly high return. Okay, okay. Because by definition, using your VC example, you know, the VC funds, I've heard things like
5000中，你知道，把所有的钱都投进去，这种非常平均的收益。但也许其中的一部分，也许是一小部分，你必须进行那些非常大的尝试，你必须限制它。但如果它，你知道，翻了1000倍，它就能带动整个投资组合。是的。所以我可以，我可以即兴发挥一下。我的意思是，我不知道我是否在过去的一期节目中提到过，但有一本很棒的书，纳西姆·尼古拉斯·塔勒布的《黑天鹅》。你读过《黑天鹅》吗？是的。是的。所以，是的，我是黑天鹅和白天鹅的坚定支持者。换句话说，就像，有……等等，白天鹅是黑天鹅的对立面吗？好吧，白天鹅，好吧，首先，白天鹅是我五秒钟前才创造的一个词。但白天鹅，但白天鹅是这个词，但白天鹅。我会把它定义为，你知道，这是一种意想不到的高回报。好的，好的。因为根据定义，使用你的风险投资例子，你知道，风险投资公司，我听说过类似的事情，
they do 100 companies and they expect one company to make up for the other 99, so it's even more extreme. But so what that means is if put yourself in the chair of a VC, when you talk to one of these hundred companies, you know, you're kind of a. expecting them to fail because, you know, statistically, they're going to be one of the 99, right? And at some point, you know, you figure out which one the one is, I'm sure. But I would consider that kind of like, like you're betting on a opposite of a black swan. Like, you're betting on an unexpected, like huge boom, right? And so, yeah, I think that, you know, otherwise you wouldn't,
他们投资100家公司，他们期望其中一家公司能弥补其他99家，所以它更极端。但这意味着，如果你把自己放在风险投资人的位置上，当你与这100家公司中的一家交谈时，你知道，你有点在期望他们失败，因为，你知道，从统计学上讲，他们将是那99家中的一家，对吧？而且在某个时候，你知道，你会弄清楚哪一家是那一家，我相信。但我会认为那有点像，就像你在押注黑天鹅的对立面。就像，你在押注一个意想不到的、巨大的繁荣，对吧？所以，是的，我认为，你知道，否则你不会，
you wouldn't really take the risk, right? If there wasn't the opposite of a, let's call it the white swan, the white swan wasn't there, the VC wouldn't do what they do, right? If one company, you know, 5xed and the other 99 went to zero, that wouldn't work. So they're kind of counting on that. And I think that is kind of a good way to look at things. I think that there's sort of certain moments where you have kind of eureka moments, or you have kind of a burst or you just get lucky.
你真的不会承担风险，对吧？如果没有黑天鹅的对立面，让我们称之为白天鹅，如果白天鹅不存在，风险投资人就不会做他们所做的事情，对吧？如果一家公司，你知道，翻了5倍，而其他99家归零，那是不行的。所以他们有点指望那个。而且我认为这是一种看待事物的好方法。我认为在某些时刻，你有某种尤里卡时刻，或者你有某种爆发，或者你只是很幸运。
And so kind of budgeting for those kind of moments, I think makes a lot of sense. And being kind of ready to really capitalize. That's the other thing is the VC hopefully is set up to where, you know, when they do find the one, that they can then, you know, 10x triple down on that one. So same kind of thing. Like you're constantly kind of exploring.
所以为这些时刻做预算，我认为很有意义。并且要做好准备真正利用好。这是另一件事，风险投资人希望被设置为，你知道，当他们确实找到那一家时，他们可以，你知道，10倍地加倍投入在那一家上。所以同样的事情。就像你一直在探索。
You see something pretty exciting. and then you kind of bet big on it. I do think that most returns are asymmetric. Oh, the other part I was going to say is, your example with investing, I think that at a large enough scale, things start to become normally distributed, right? So in other words,
你看到一些非常令人兴奋的事情，然后你就在上面下大赌注。我确实认为大多数回报是不对称的。哦，我要说的另一部分是，你关于投资的例子，我认为在足够大的规模下，事情开始呈正态分布，对吧？所以换句话说，
like if Broadcom has like a killer year, well, it doesn't really matter if you've invested. in, I don't know if they're in the SMP 500, but if you, if you invested in all SMP 500, then their killer year gets sort of diluted, right? So like at scale, you don't really have black swans or white swans, at least you hope, which is the reason why we can all be sort of comfortable. We're not just anxiety ridden as, as we get older, right? So I think that that at scale, when I think about investing, as someone who's not a very,
如果博通（Broadcom）有一个杀手级的一年，嗯，如果你投资了，这并不重要。在，我不知道他们是否在标普500中，但如果你，如果你投资了所有的标普500，那么他们杀手级的一年就会被稀释，对吧？所以，在规模上，你并没有真正的黑天鹅或白天鹅，至少你希望如此，这就是为什么我们都可以感到某种舒适。随着年龄的增长，我们不会只是充满焦虑，对吧？所以我认为在规模上，当我想到投资时，作为一个不是非常，
savvy investor at all, you know, I just think, well, their returns are going to be normally distributed around 5% or 8% or whatever it is. But then individually, or when I look at things at a smaller scale, I do think the returns are often asymmetric. Yeah, I think I might have mixed up sort of two things I might not. So the one your Rift-on is good. So I think there's like taking it to career growth, not that we always have to talk about that, but taking, I actually believe I I was bringing this up the other day. Most places, we overestimate the impact of a failure. Like, if you really, if your boss came and asked you, hey, do you want to try this like really hard thing? You're like, I'm like, I'm not sure. Like, what's really the downside of failing? Like, I think most of the time in most cases, in all cases, you know, this is not universal advice. I'm not a lawyer, I guess. But like most cases, the risk of failing is pretty low. So it's actually really capped to the downside, you know. And, And it's, I guess, maybe similar to the VC example. The chance of the VC having money taken away from them is non-existent.
精明的投资者，你知道，我只是想，嗯，他们的回报将在5%或8%左右呈正态分布，或者无论它是多少。但随后单独来看，或者当我以较小的规模看待事物时，我确实认为回报通常是不对称的。是的，我想我可能把两件事混在一起了，我可能没有。所以你即兴发挥的那部分很好。所以我认为有像职业成长这样的事情，并不是说我们总是要谈论这个，但采取，我实际上相信我前几天提到了这一点。大多数地方，我们高估了失败的影响。就像，如果你真的，如果你的老板来问你，嘿，你想尝试这个非常困难的事情吗？你就像，我像，我不确定。就像，失败的下行空间到底是什么？就像，我认为大多数时候在大多数情况下，在所有情况下，你知道，这不是普遍的建议。我不是律师，我想。但就像大多数情况下，失败的风险很低。所以它实际上在下行空间上被真正限制了，你知道。而且，而且它是，我猜，也许类似于风险投资的例子。风险投资人被拿走钱的机会是不存在的。
So the worst case is capped at zero, but the top case is uncapped. So if they do really bad, if 100 out of 100 fail, they lose all their money that they invested. But it doesn't mean they invested all their money. Correct. But if one goes to Facebook scale or whatever, you know, then all of a sudden, you know, they're filthy rich. And so I think that's probably a good mapping. I think there's another thing I was trying to slide in there,
所以最坏的情况被限制在零，但最好的情况是不设上限的。所以如果他们做得非常糟糕，如果100家中有100家失败，他们会损失他们投资的所有钱。但这并不意味着他们投资了所有的钱。正确。但如果有一家达到了Facebook的规模或类似规模，你知道，那么突然之间，你知道，他们就富得流油了。所以我认为这可能是一个很好的映射。我认为我试图塞进去的另一件事，
but maybe now thinking about it, I muddy the water. I think it's separate, which is just like individual performance day to day. So like taking opportunities and getting that exposure, but then day to day, trying to set yourself up so that like, like you're getting the reps in,
但现在想来，我把水搅浑了。我认为它是分开的，这只是像日常的个人表现。所以就像抓住机会并获得那种暴露，但随后每天，试图为自己设定目标，以便像，就像你在进行重复练习，
you're getting practice in, like you're getting yourself like training and skill and like setting your expectations for yourself maybe higher, knowing that sometimes you're not going to do as well, and then realizing when you practice being at a higher level that you're going to get similarly, it's not exactly the same though, I guess, but you're going to get those outperformance days.
你在进行练习，就像你在让自己进行训练和技能提升，并且可能把对自己的期望设定得更高，知道有时你不会做得那么好，然后意识到当你练习处于更高水平时，你会同样地，虽然我不确定这是否完全一样，但你会得到那些超额表现的日子。
And those outperformance days may shock you with just, like I've had that before. You call it kind of like Eureka moment. You're like doing some work. And being up at that higher level, you're going to potentially see more of them where it's just like, what was I thinking that? It was amazing.
而那些超额表现的日子可能会让你感到震惊，就像我以前有过那样。你称之为某种尤里卡时刻。你就像在做一些工作。并且处于那个更高的水平，你可能会看到更多这样的时刻，就像，我当时在想什么？这太棒了。
Like, how do I get that in a bottle? Like, I would love to be like that every day. And it doesn't happen often, but I do feel like it happens more often when I'm operating at a high, not burning out, but when I'm expecting more out of myself and performing at a high level. Yeah, I think that makes a lot of sense. I think that similar to the VC, you know, having that money to invest in the next round, like you also need to balance your work and life so that when you do have like that eureka moment, you can kind of really triple down on that. And then go back to a more healthy state. So I think, I don't know if we have a term for this in my family, but, but there is kind of like this notion, like, oh, you know, dad's going into some workhole, you know, he's going to come back in like a couple of days or something.
就像，我怎么能把它装进瓶子里？就像，我希望每天都能那样。这并不经常发生，但我确实觉得当我处于高水平运作时，不是精疲力竭，而是当我对自己期望更高并以高水平表现时，它发生得更频繁。是的，我认为这很有道理。我认为类似于风险投资，你知道，有那笔钱可以投资下一轮，就像你也需要平衡你的工作和生活，以便当你确实有那种尤里卡时刻时，你可以真正地加倍投入。然后回到更健康的状态。所以我认为，我不知道我们在我的家庭里是否有这个词，但是，但是确实有这种概念，就像，哦，你知道，爸爸要进入某种工作洞了，你知道，他会在几天内回来或者什么的。
I call it the fugue, but yeah. The fugue? Yeah, isn't that like an organ thing where like the organ music gets really loud and like, you know. Oh, look at you. I've never, never, that's an SAT word I've never heard. I have to look it up. Maybe, yeah, a fugue state. Here we go.
我称之为“赋格”（fugue），但确实。赋格？是的，那不是像管风琴的东西，管风琴音乐变得非常大声，就像，你知道。哦，看看你。我从来没有，从来没有，那是一个我从未听说过的SAT词汇。我得查一下。也许，是的，赋格状态。我们开始吧。
In music. Yeah, it's a fugue state is a disassociated. It's a psychological environment. So I'm unexpected. Oh, wait, this is bad. No, this is like you have amnesia. What? I completely, okay, maybe I'm thinking, I guess I'm thinking of it.
在音乐中。是的，赋格状态是一种解离。这是一种心理环境。所以我很意外。哦，等等，这很糟糕。不，这就像你有失忆症。什么？我完全，好吧，也许我在想，我猜我在想它。
Oh, Patrick's going dementia again, girls. Oh, no. Oh, no. Hang on. I don't know. Maybe I'm just using this wrong. Oh, well. It's a word.
哦，Patrick又要痴呆了，姑娘们。哦，不。哦，不。等等。我不知道。也许我只是用错了。哦，好吧。这是一个词。
Like you said, maybe you just need to define a new word. It's like a flow state. That's why I think the like, you know, anyways. Okay, but yeah, I just made up a new word for it apparently because this doesn't match any existing definition. So if you use this, don't expect anyone to know what it is. You know, just, okay, kind of, maybe this is too much of a segue, but you made me think of another thing. I used to coach, you know, high level I sees at Facebook. So basically, I mean, obviously, like there's, I wasn't the highest level.
就像你说的，也许你只需要定义一个新词。这就像一种心流状态。这就是为什么我认为像，你知道，无论如何。好吧，但是是的，我显然刚刚为它编造了一个新词，因为它不符合任何现有的定义。所以如果你使用这个，不要指望任何人知道它是什么。你知道，只是，好吧，有点，也许这太像一个过渡了，但你让我想到了另一件事。我曾经在Facebook指导高水平的个人贡献者（IC）。所以基本上，我的意思是，显然，就像有，我不是最高水平。
So there's people above me and everything. But specifically, people who are trying to go either from five to six or six to seven, I did a bunch of one-on-one coaching, and then I ran this thing called the IC Circle, where we would just do more like one-to-many coaching, but it was more of like a community type thing. And one thing really struck me. This person said they didn't want, this was one-on-one. They said they didn't want to go to level six. because if you look at the stats,
所以有比我更高的人等等。但具体来说，那些试图从5级升到6级或6级升到7级的人，我做了一堆一对一的指导，然后我运行了一个叫做IC圈的东西，在那里我们只是做更多像一对多的指导，但它更像是一个社区类型的东西。有一件事真的让我印象深刻。这个人说他们不想，这是一对一的。他们说他们不想升到6级。因为如果你看统计数据，
you're something like 15 times more likely to get fired if you're level six than if you're level five for performance. And they're like, well, you know, I kind of want to take this promotion. They also were, I think they were on a visa. I mean, it's definitely part of it. But they just felt like, well, my expected value is zero if I get fired.
如果你是6级，你因为表现而被解雇的可能性比5级高出15倍左右。他们就像，嗯，你知道，我有点想接受这次晋升。他们也，我想他们是持签证的。我的意思是，这绝对是其中的一部分。但他们只是觉得，嗯，如果我被解雇，我的期望值是零。
And so keeping that probability low, is uh actually yeah but you're looking yeah i guess it's not zero you get a job somewhere else but my point is like your your expected value at meta is zero if they fire you right um but uh and and so the the the raise that the level six compensation is higher but not higher enough to justify that right so anyway what i told what i told this person at the time was um was was basically you know okay i totally get it there is and there I think there was kind of an issue with this people at six and above just getting getting fired for performance I said but you know plan for the future don't really plan for the present so like okay the present situation is you're looking around
所以保持这种低概率，是啊，实际上是的，但你在看，是的，我猜它不是零，你在别处找到工作，但我的意思是，如果你被解雇，你在Meta的期望值是零，对吧，嗯，但是，6级的薪酬更高，但没有高到足以证明这一点，对吧？所以无论如何，我当时告诉这个人的是，嗯，基本上，你知道，好吧，我完全理解，确实存在，而且我认为6级及以上的人因为表现而被解雇确实存在某种问题，我说，但你知道，为未来做计划，不要真的为现在做计划，所以就像，好吧，现在的情况是你环顾四周，
and you're seeing the level six is on your team getting getting sit home but that's you can't kind of base the future on the present um and I think that that um but I think that, yeah, you have to kind of, like the asymmetric returns kind of kicks in where, you know, by taking that chance and getting, getting that promotion now, you know, you can always kind of figure out your steady state afterwards. What you can't do, or it's very hard to control, is having that amazing, you know, product launch that causes you to get a promotion. Like, in other words, If you have an asymmetric return and you don't capitalize on it, it might be very, very hard to bounce back from that. But if you do capitalize on it, and then let's say, worst case, you know, you get fired for performance at the next level, I still feel like that was the right call. And just to finish the story out, the person didn't get fired. They're actually still at Facebook happily at their level. So, I mean, this got talked about not me, but by people in the field, financial people when Facebook was.
你看到你团队里的6级员工被送回家，但你不能把未来建立在现在之上，我认为，是的，你必须，就像不对称回报开始发挥作用，你知道，通过抓住那个机会并现在获得那个晋升，你知道，你总是可以弄清楚你之后的稳定状态。你不能做，或者很难控制的是拥有那个令人惊叹的，你知道，导致你获得晋升的产品发布。换句话说，如果你有一个不对称的回报，而你没有利用它，那么从那之后反弹可能会非常非常困难。但如果你确实利用了它，然后假设，最坏的情况，你知道，你在下一个级别因为表现而被解雇，我仍然觉得那是正确的决定。为了讲完这个故事，那个人没有被解雇。他们实际上仍然在Facebook快乐地处于他们的级别。所以，我的意思是，这被谈论过，不是我，而是当Facebook在
doing the outsized bonuses for hiring AI people. I think they've turned it down now, but they were saying a little bit of a similar thing, there's an expectation of a continuing current state. So in other words, I don't have to take this right now because I could take it in 12 months or 24 months. And in reality, actually it turned out,
为招聘AI人员提供超额奖金时，领域内的人，金融界的人。我想他们现在已经拒绝了，但他们说的是类似的事情，有一种对持续当前状态的期望。换句话说，我不必现在就接受这个，因为我可以在12个月或24个月后接受它。而实际上，它结果是，
it was like a window of like 30 days. Yeah. It was like really short. But it's sort of to what you were saying, those opportunities you think they're, they're going to come at some even spacing or always and it's that's not right it's not true your ability to get a promotion your ability to be on that project your ability to start something new greenfield make your mark whatever those things aren't evenly distributed in time and so yeah i yeah i agree with
那就像一个30天的窗口。是的。它非常短。但这有点像你所说的，那些你认为它们会以某种均匀的间隔出现或者总是出现的机会，那是不对的，那不是真的，你获得晋升的能力，你参与那个项目的能力，你开始新事物、开辟新领域、留下印记的能力，无论那些事情是什么，它们在时间上不是均匀分布的，所以是的，我，是的，我同意
you all right so just to follow up i i did find the correct definition of you i wasn't that crazy although it apparently have a slightly negative connotation but it means to do something where you're completely aware and focus but afterwards you can't remember what happened. And so that sounds perfect. That's actually exactly what. So actually it took me a little bit of searching. Apparently it's a very deep, like a back catalog definition. It's like what, what idiot wrote this code? And it was you a week ago. Yes. No, no. That's what I like you get really focused and you turn out all this stuff. My new one is writing code and then like having other people sort of help me like finish it off or whatever and then submit it under their names. And then I think they wrote the code.
你。好吧，所以为了跟进，我确实找到了“赋格”的正确定义，我并没有那么疯狂，尽管它显然有一点负面含义，但它意味着做某事时你完全意识到并专注，但事后你记不住发生了什么。所以这听起来很完美。这实际上正是。所以实际上我花了一点时间搜索。显然这是一个非常深层的，像一个旧目录定义。就像什么白痴写的这段代码？而那是一周前的你。是的。不，不。这就是我喜欢的，你变得非常专注，然后你产出了所有这些东西。我的新东西是写代码，然后让其他人帮我完成它或者什么的，然后以他们的名义提交。然后我想他们写了代码。
and they're like, no, you wrote this code. Oops. All right. All right. Time for news. You're up first. All right. I'm up first.
他们就像，不，是你写的这段代码。哎呀。好吧。好吧。新闻时间。你先来。好吧。我先来。
So it won't be this weekend when this comes out, but that's okay. Just recently, Andre Carpathy, I believe is how you say his name. You know, he's gained some renown recently for a little bit being the people's AI person, I guess. Like, you know, he's not running a big AI company. He clearly knows. knows what he's doing, he can explain concepts, but he explains them in depth. Let me, let me add a little bit of color there. So Andre was the head of AI Tesla, and he left, and he basically is like, I don't want to say retire. That's not the right word because he's very
所以当这期节目出来时，不会是这个周末，但这没关系。就在最近，安德烈·卡帕西（Andre Karpathy），我相信是这样发音他的名字。你知道，他最近因为有点成为人民的AI人物而获得了一些声誉，我想。就像，你知道，他没有经营一家大型AI公司。他显然知道他在做什么，他可以解释概念，但他深入地解释它们。让我，让我增加一点色彩。所以安德烈曾是特斯拉AI的负责人，他离开了，他基本上是，我不想说退休。那不是正确的词，因为他非常
productive, but he quit to do exactly this, like to just build things for the people and teach the people. And so he's, he's in a way like doing some monastic work right now. well do we talk about SAT words monastic oh there we go look at this man you think people thought they were coming here to talk about programming so you know in some ways actually I think to your thank you for that actually that's color comment is very good you know I think our podcast tries to be although I don't say we're as effective as this something in a similar vein trying to break down stuff for folks he released a new
富有成效，但他辞职就是为了做这件事，就像为了人民建造东西并教导人民。所以他，他在某种程度上就像现在在做一些修道院式的工作。好吧，我们谈论SAT词汇“修道院式”吗？哦，我们开始吧，看看这个人，你以为人们来这里是为了谈论编程。所以你知道，在某些方面，实际上我认为对你的，谢谢你，实际上那个色彩评论非常好，你知道，我认为我们的播客试图成为，虽然我不敢说我们像那样有效，但类似的事情试图为人们分解东西，他发布了一个新的
GitHub repo, sort of out of the blue, as far as I know, I don't think he was, I didn't know he was working on it, called NanoChat. And NanoChat is, previously he had done some other sort of examples of training, I don't say like toy, but like Toy Transformer networks and models and getting them up to sort of GPT2 level, sort of, you know, trying to be two level. Like, like, wow, okay, it's just better than if you, if you remember, oh, I don't know, a while ago, a decade ago, people were doing hidden Markov models trained on, you know, Harry Potter. And it would produce words that, like, if you didn't look too closely, they kind of look like maybe sentences, but they didn't make any sense. And then, you know, we kind of got into the chat GPTs. These GPDs
GitHub仓库，有点出乎意料，据我所知，我不知道他在做这个，叫做NanoChat。而NanoChat是，之前他做过一些其他类型的训练例子，我不说像玩具，但像玩具Transformer网络和模型，并让它们达到GPT2水平，试图成为2级水平。就像，哇，好吧，它只是比如果你，如果你记得，哦，我不知道，十年前，人们在做基于哈利波特的隐马尔可夫模型。它会产生单词，就像，如果你不仔细看，它们看起来可能像句子，但它们没有任何意义。然后，你知道，我们进入了聊天GPT。这些GPT
are good. So he's sort of done some of that before. But now sort of what he's done is done an end-to-end, pre-training, doing the chat UI, you know, constructing the models and everything end-to-end in a single repost. You can really kind of study it. And really awesomely, if you don't know, training the frontier models, I don't even know what the estimates are now like $10 million to train to train one. They're very, very, very expensive. So most training outside of the
很好。所以他之前做过一些那样的东西。但现在他所做的是做了一个端到端的，预训练，做聊天UI，你知道，构建模型和所有东西，端到端在一个单一的仓库中。你可以真正地研究它。而且非常棒的是，如果你不知道，训练前沿模型，我甚至不知道现在的估计是多少，比如1000万美元来训练一个。它们非常非常非常昂贵。所以大多数训练，除了
maybe 10 companies in the world is doing fine-tuning, you know, other small things, but not the sort of pre-training. That's reserved for people have much more money to burn than myself. Yeah, and 10 million, I think, just is one instance.
世界上可能10家公司之外，都在做微调，你知道，其他小事情，但不是那种预训练。那是留给那些比我有更多钱可以烧的人的。是的，1000万，我想，只是一个实例。
So it's like if you miss a colon, I mean, you're going to catch earlier than that. But like in theory, If you have some data issue, now it's another 10 million. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, who knows how many times they have to do it. Yeah, that's right. And that was a big thing.
所以就像如果你漏掉了一个冒号，我的意思是，你会比那更早发现。但就像理论上，如果你有数据问题，现在又是1000万。是的，是的，是的。谁知道他们必须做多少次。是的，那是对的。那是一件大事。
If you were called Deep Seat getting really popular for, you know, they had their moment. They've kind of, you know, taken a little step back, you know, in terms of in the, you know, general awareness. But that was their big thing was doing some of this pre-training cheaper. Okay. Anyways, back to the story. So Andre's Carpathy's repo also made it so that you could do all of this for $100. now $100 isn't nothing but I'll make a couple observations so first one is again compared to that other amount people spend more than that go play a round of golf you know go do something
如果你被称为Deep Seat，因为，你知道，他们有他们的时刻。他们已经，你知道，退后了一步，你知道，在一般意识中。但那是他们的大事，就是更便宜地做一些这种预训练。好吧。无论如何，回到故事。所以安德烈·卡帕西的仓库也使得你可以用100美元做所有这些。现在100美元不是什么都没有，但我会做几个观察，所以第一个是再次与人们花费的那个金额相比，去打一场高尔夫球，你知道，去做点什么
you know it it is a lot of money I don't want to diminish it but it is enough like if you're doing it for learning if you're doing it for understanding if you're you know really getting into this it's attainable it's a hobbyist level amount that you could spend which is awesome on sort of relatively reasonable spec hardware and he has the scripts for doing all of it sort of set up, which is really awesome. But then, of course, the second observation I'll make is twofold. One, the cost for his stuff will go down. If you wait, you know, six months, 12 months, I would expect it to be cheaper as new hardware and instances and supply come online. But the second thing is as a general sort of observation, a lot of this stuff, this is where
你知道，它确实是一大笔钱，我不想贬低它，但它足够了，如果你是为了学习，如果你是为了理解，如果你，你知道，真的进入了这个领域，它是可达到的，这是一个业余爱好者水平的金额，你可以花，这在某种程度上是相当合理的规格硬件上，而且他有做所有这些的脚本，这真的很棒。但当然，我会做的第二个观察是双重的。第一，他的东西的成本会下降。如果你等，你知道，六个月，12个月，我预计随着新硬件和实例以及供应上线，它会更便宜。但第二件事是作为一个一般的观察，很多这些东西，这就是
you're seeing the growth. You know, we're not seeing chat GPT. whatever, five, or any of these other things become two X better, three X better. It's not really happening, but the cost to train, the cost to run inference is all coming down dramatically. And here, you know, I think is a little bit of an example of, you know, sort of the rise in the hobbyist stuff and the decline of the cost, you know, you're coming to, you know, not exactly at meeting point, but coming and converging together to where we can start to not get to state of the art, but push to something that five years ago would have been like, Oh my gosh, like you did all of this run.
你看到增长的地方。你知道，我们没有看到聊天GPT，无论什么，5，或者任何其他东西变得好2倍，好3倍。它并没有真正发生，但训练的成本，运行推理的成本都在急剧下降。在这里，你知道，我认为是一个小例子，你知道，业余爱好者东西的兴起和成本的下降，你知道，你来到，你知道，不完全是交汇点，但正在汇聚在一起，我们可以开始不达到最先进水平，但推动到五年前会像，哦，天哪，你做了所有这些运行。
That would be crazy. So it's a reminder of the insane progress we're saying. Yeah, totally. Yeah. I think it's a really good kind of recap. Yeah, I mean, this stuff's super exciting. I think a lot of the innovation now is, and I think Andres actually talks about this,
那会很疯狂。所以这是一个提醒，我们正在看到的疯狂进步。是的，完全。是的。我认为这是一个非常好的回顾。是的，我的意思是，这些东西超级令人兴奋。我认为现在很多创新是，而且我认为安德烈实际上谈到了这一点，
is around, you know, reverse engineering the best possible prompt. I don't know if I brought this up, but I don't think we have. I had a situation at my current job about a month or two ago. We changed models. So a model that we were using was deprecated. And so we moved on to the next version of the same model. And the performance went way, way down, like really, really far down. Like, went from maybe 80% to 7% kind of thing.
是关于，你知道，逆向工程出最好的提示词。我不知道我是否提到了这一点，但我认为我们没有。我大约一个月或两个月前在目前的工作中遇到过这种情况。我们更换了模型。所以我们正在使用的模型被弃用了。所以我们转向了同一个模型的下一个版本。而性能下降了很多，真的，真的下降了很多。就像从可能80%下降到7%左右。
And after a lot of debugging and kind of, you know, looking at a lot of numbers, we realized that all we had to do is change the so we had a prompt that was about three or four sentences in a paragraph if we swapped the first two sentences the performance went back to 80 percent so so basically like the the ordering of the sentences the way the thoughts are and it's not like it wasn't illogical the first way right it was two independent thoughts and they just if you switch the order massive improvement and so what that says to me is that we humans shouldn't be writing these prompts. I mean, you know, we write the first version,
而在大量的调试和，你知道，查看大量数字之后，我们意识到我们所要做的只是改变，所以我们有一个提示词，大约是段落中的三或四句话，如果我们交换前两句话，性能就回到了80%。所以基本上，就像句子的顺序，思想的方式，而且它不像，它在第一种方式中并不不合逻辑，对吧？它是两个独立的思想，它们只是如果你交换顺序，巨大的改进。所以这对我来说意味着我们人类不应该写这些提示词。我的意思是，你知道，我们写第一个版本，
but like at the bare minimum, you know, we should have a system that just like reorders them a few different ways that picks the best ordering. Like somehow breaks them into independent thoughts and then tries different permutations. But at the limit, it would be, you know, some type of feedback mechanism
但就像在最低限度，你知道，我们应该有一个系统，只是像以几种不同的方式重新排序它们，选择最好的排序。就像以某种方式把它们分解成独立的思想，然后尝试不同的排列。但在极限情况下，它将是，你知道，某种反馈机制
that's constantly updating all of these prompts. But that I think is where I'm, seeing kind of a lot of the innovation and I think it's because of cost exactly you know as you said when it costs 10 million to train a model um what we ultimately need and I think nano chat's a good way of getting there is you know a set of benchmarks and a set of models that are small and trained for very cheap um and then you can you know learn learn some insight someone can invent the next thing right like maybe it's SSM maybe it's a diffusion chat models right someone invents the next thing and then it's it blows
不断更新所有这些提示词。但我认为这就是我，看到某种创新，而且我认为这是因为成本，正如你所说，当训练一个模型需要1000万时，我们最终需要的是，而且我认为NanoChat是一个很好的实现方式，你知道，一套基准和一套很小且训练成本非常便宜的模型，然后你可以，你知道，学习一些见解，有人可以发明下一个东西，对吧？也许是SSM，也许是扩散聊天模型，有人发明了下一个东西，然后它把
everything else out of its weight class but but it's still nowhere near chat GPT but but it totally dominates the very cheap chat GPT and so then you could say okay this is now worth spending 10 million I mean I guess that's partly where I think the running local models you know on your whatever home home smart device, your personal assistant on your phone. We were just checking before briefly. There's a cloud outage this morning. So that happens from time to time. And so I think having some of these models run locally.
其他所有东西都吹出了它的重量级，但它仍然远不及聊天GPT，但它完全主导了非常便宜的聊天GPT。所以你可以说，好吧，这现在值得花1000万。我的意思是，我猜这部分是我认为在你的任何家庭智能设备上运行本地模型，你的手机上的个人助理。我们刚才简要检查了一下。今天早上有云中断。所以这种情况时有发生。所以我认为让其中一些模型在本地运行。
And I think when they hardware get sophisticated enough and the models get distilled enough to be like absolutely actually useful in those things, I bet you would see a lot more investment into into that as like a focused product that you can have. Like, what has state of the art for a capped size model, not unbounded? Right. Yeah, exactly. All right. My news article is Pidentic AI. To be totally honest, I picked a random news article.
而且我认为当硬件变得足够复杂，模型变得足够精简，以至于在那些东西中绝对真正有用时，我敢打赌你会看到更多的投资进入到那个作为一个你可以拥有的专注产品。就像，什么是上限大小模型的最先进水平，而不是无界的？对。是的，完全。好吧。我的新闻文章是Pidentic AI。老实说，我随机挑选了一篇新闻文章。
I really just wanted to talk about Pidentic AI. I could have made it a tool, but I had a different tool. So this is really cool. I used this the other day. I built a very simple test, like a prototype. So I downloaded, remember PC Part Picker? Yes. Remember that website?
我真的只是想谈谈Pidentic AI。我可以把它做成一个工具，但我有另一个工具。所以这真的很酷。我前几天用了这个。我建立了一个非常简单的测试，就像一个原型。所以我下载了，记得PC Part Picker吗？是的。记得那个网站吗？
Yeah, I don't know if they're still around, but someone posted basically CSV files of all the inventory of PC Part Picker. So there's a CSV file for heat sinks, a CSV file for processors, et cetera, et cetera. And I use Pidantic AI, which is this way to build AI agents, which we should probably do an entire show on,
是的，我不知道他们是否还在，但有人发布了PC Part Picker所有库存的CSV文件。所以有一个散热器的CSV文件，一个处理器的CSV文件，等等，等等。我使用了Pidantic AI，这是构建AI代理的一种方式，我们可能应该为此做一个完整的节目，
but it's taking off, and I think it's very interesting. And I only give it access to one tool, and the tool is you know, DuckDB? We've probably talked about this. So the tool literally is you can,
但它正在起飞，而且我认为它非常有趣。而且我只给它一个工具的访问权限，这个工具是，你知道DuckDB吗？我们可能谈论过这个。所以这个工具字面上是你可以，
you pass in which CSV file you're interested in, video cards, CPU, etc. And DuckDB SQL query. And this, this AI tool opens at CSV, runs a query, returns back the results. And so that was it. And so this whole AI agent thing with Pidentic AI, it was like 80 lines of code or something. And now I have this
你传入你感兴趣的CSV文件，显卡，CPU等。以及DuckDB SQL查询。而这个，这个AI工具打开那个CSV，运行一个查询，返回结果。所以就是这样。所以这个带有Pidentic AI的整个AI代理东西，它大约是80行代码或者什么的。现在我有这个
thing where you can ask it to build you computers. Like you can literally type in, hey, I want a computer with the NVIDIA GPU, at least 16 gig of Vram for under $2,000. And it will actually build a computer for you out of all those parts and it runs SQL queries and you can actually see all the steps. First, it runs like a described select on each of the CSV file so it can get all the schemas of them all. And then it starts running queries. Sometimes it'll type in a query that doesn't compile. DuckDB will like send an error back and Pidentic can act will actually catch errors and turn them into strings and send those strings back to the AI. So the AI, like, got an error and was like, oh, I need to change the query. And it did. And it eventually
东西，你可以要求它为你组装电脑。就像你可以字面上输入，嘿，我想要一台带有NVIDIA GPU，至少16GB显存，价格低于2000美元的电脑。它实际上会用所有那些零件为你组装一台电脑，它运行SQL查询，你可以实际看到所有的步骤。首先，它运行像每个CSV文件上的描述选择，这样它就可以获得它们所有的模式。然后它开始运行查询。有时它会输入一个无法编译的查询。DuckDB会像发回一个错误，而Pidentic AI实际上会捕获错误并将它们转换为字符串，并将那些字符串发回给AI。所以AI，就像，得到了一个错误，并且就像，哦，我需要更改查询。它确实做了。它最终
gets there. And it generates, like, builds PCs that are good. So, but, but I just found this amazing. And I'm sure there are other tools out there, but I just, I couldn't believe how in just a matter of hours, I was able to go from nothing to all that. That is really cool. I mean, it's really, like, commoditizing. Yeah, it's coming to the fact that, yeah, We can do that and it's super cool. Yeah. So if you're doing agentic stuff, this is the same company that made Piedantic,
到达了那里。它生成，就像，组装出好的PC。所以，但我只是觉得这太神奇了。而且我相信外面有其他工具，但我只是，我无法相信在短短几个小时内，我就能从无到有做到这一切。这真的很酷。我的意思是，它真的，就像，商品化。是的，它正在来到这样一个事实，是的，我们可以做到这一点，而且它超级酷。是的。所以如果你在做代理工作，这是制造Pidentic的同一家公司，
which is a, which is kind of like a data class system that's very popular and really well done. Actually, the same people made SQL model and fast API and like a ton of amazing libraries. So this is also, you know, walking in good footsteps. My next news article is something that I actually botched and then it was amazing how it was amazing before it was amazing. Okay, here we go.
这是一种数据类系统，非常流行且做得非常好。实际上，同一群人制造了SQL model和fast API以及一吨令人惊叹的库。所以这也是，你知道，走在好的足迹上。我的下一篇新闻文章是我实际上搞砸了的东西，然后它很神奇，在它神奇之前它就很神奇。好吧，我们开始吧。
So I saw this news article and it was 1,000 Starlink after a launch this, again, this weekend from SpaceX. So all those Starlink satellites up. And there's been actually a huge thing like the amounts of money they're making. It's a private company still owned by SpaceX. But the number of subscribers, they have like as far as like a tech store. It's actually really astonishing. I would love to have invested, would invest. It's private.
所以我看到了这篇新闻文章，它是1000颗星链（Starlink）在发射之后，再次，这个周末来自SpaceX。所以所有那些星链卫星都上去了。而且实际上有一件巨大的事情，就像他们赚的钱的数量。它仍然是一家由SpaceX拥有的私营公司。但订阅者的数量，他们有像，就科技商店而言。这实际上真的很令人惊讶。我很想投资，会投资。它是私有的。
So it's a bit of a thorny issue to try to get access. But this is a great idea. I'm really for it. But we saw this. I was talking about it that, you know, there's a thousand, thousand satellites. And then I was like, wait a minute. Hang on. Let me look at this again.
所以试图获得访问权限是一个有点棘手的问题。但这是一个好主意。我真的很支持它。但我们看到了这个。我当时在谈论它，你知道，有一千，一千颗卫星。然后我就像，等等。等等。让我再看看这个。
And it's, you know, oh, it was a thousand Starlink satellites had been launched in 2025 so far. So, but I thought was like, yeah, what I already thought was amazing is like, oh, there's a thousand of these satellites, you know, orbiting around. How cool is this? It's like, no, that's incorrect. There has been a thousand launch to this year. So then I, wait a minute, how many are there?
你知道吗，2025年至今已经发射了一千颗星链卫星。我原本以为这已经很了不起了，心想“哇，有上千颗卫星在轨道上运行，太酷了”。但其实不对，今年就已经发射了一千颗。所以我当时就想，等等，那到底有多少颗？
And it's like 8,400 and something in orbit. There are so many in orbit now that actually every single day, one to two Starlink satellites incinerate back into the atmosphere from. sort of end of lifing, which is expected. So they put them into, you know, relatively low Earth orbit. So there are orbits, you know, there's a little bit of air friction and whatever. They naturally decay. They're meant to do that.
大概有8400多颗在轨道上。现在轨道上的卫星多到每天都有一两颗星链卫星因为寿命到期而坠入大气层焚毁，这是预料之中的。它们被放置在相对较低的地球轨道上，那里有一点空气阻力之类的，它们会自然衰减，这本来就是设计好的。
You don't want them staying up forever and, you know, getting obsolete and then just drifting around a space junk. So they actually think they do a process for, you know, intentionally sort of making it. So they'll deorbit, you know, deliberately rather than just, you know, chaotically. But basically there have been so many gone up. going up that one to two every single day are just basically burning up and it's still this like insanely lucrative business doing all this crazy stuff and there are 8,000 found a visualizer you can click and actually see all of them because there's you know sort of orbit information is known and
你肯定不希望它们永远留在天上，变得过时，然后变成太空垃圾到处漂浮。所以他们确实有一个流程，让它们有目的地脱离轨道，而不是任由其混乱坠落。基本上，发射的数量太多了，以至于每天都有一两颗在焚毁。这仍然是一项极其赚钱的业务，而且有8000多颗，你可以找到一个可视化工具点击查看它们，因为轨道信息是公开的。
it turns out orbital mechanics is like well understood so you can actually just go and visualize the entire like mesh of all of the orbits which is very well planned to get nice coverage You can see new ones that are being deployed are like clustered together and slowly drift to their, I guess, station. I'm not familiar with the term. But it's absolutely bonkers just to think about the scale of this. And I don't think maybe I've talked about on the podcast
事实证明，轨道力学是非常成熟的，所以你可以直接去可视化整个轨道网，为了获得良好的覆盖范围，这些轨道规划得非常好。你可以看到新部署的卫星聚在一起，然后慢慢漂移到它们的位置，我不知道这个术语叫什么。但想到这种规模，简直太疯狂了。我不确定我是否在播客里谈过这个，
before, but I was talking about it with some local friend group, you know, just sort of how if you had said this, you know, whatever, 10 years ago, like, oh, yeah, there's like this darling thing. It's roughly competitive with broadband. It works great. You can play video games on it. Like it's not super laggy. It's in this little dish,
但我之前和当地的朋友圈聊过，如果你在十年前说：“嘿，有个叫星链的东西，它和宽带差不多，效果很好，你可以在上面玩电子游戏，延迟也不高，就在这个小碟子里。”
just flat dish thing and people would be like what no that and then now people are like yeah of course that's called Starlink like yeah I have that in my cabin yeah it's it's from do they have coverage in the ocean or like do how does that work is it the kind of thing where it's only in places where there that can be populated or is it literally circumnavigating they have slightly different fee structure I'm not clear if it's because they can or because there's a reason but no people have it on like their ships on their traveling RVs on their boats yeah there and now the this weekend or whatever they're demoing and i guess maybe some people still don't know this but there was like a couple weekends ago or whatever they were talking about
就是一个扁平的碟子，人们会说“什么？不，那不可能”。但现在人们会说“哦，那是星链，我小屋里就有，它在海洋里有覆盖吗？还是说它只能在有人居住的地方使用？它是真的环绕地球吗？”他们的收费结构略有不同，我不清楚是因为技术原因还是其他原因，但人们确实在船上、房车上使用它。而且这个周末他们还在演示，可能有些人还不知道，就在几周前，他们谈到了
one of the airlines i want to say united or american here in the united states was going to be putting starling dishes on all of the planes which they've used a different satellite provider so if you've ever gotten satellite on an airplane it's you know it's not very good yeah um But now they were like flying this reporter up and sort of they were able to take a FaceTime call and it felt like normal. And they were like from an airplane. And they were just like their mind was sort of like blown that, you know, flying through Spain. I think Elon Musk even ended up retweeting about it. And he's like, well, if you're traveling whatever the orbital speed, I won't quote it, because I'll get it wrong of a Starlink satellite.
美国的一家航空公司，我想是美联航或美国航空，要在所有飞机上安装星链天线。他们之前用的是其他卫星提供商，如果你在飞机上用过卫星网络，你就知道那体验并不好。但现在他们让一位记者飞上去，他们能够进行FaceTime通话，感觉就像在地面一样。他们当时在飞机上，简直惊呆了，飞机正飞越西班牙。我想埃隆·马斯克甚至转发了这件事，他说：“如果你以星链卫星的轨道速度飞行——我就不引用具体数字了，因为我可能会记错——”
He's like, even airplanes look basically still. And so you know, you think flying through an airplane like, oh my gosh, it's moving so fast. Aren't there going to be all of this? He's like, no, they basically look like they're standing still because we're flying so fast. Wow, that's incredible. And so it's just this interesting sort of normalization of what is just absolutely. It's rocket science, right? Like just all of this stuff, you know, being up there and going around.
他说：“即使是飞机看起来也基本是静止的。”所以你觉得在飞机上飞得很快，心想“天哪，它移动得这么快，不会有干扰吗？”他说：“不，它们看起来就像静止不动，因为我们飞得太快了。”哇，这太不可思议了。这是一种有趣的常态化，这就是火箭科学，对吧？所有这些东西都在那里运行。
So when the Starlink satellites are, you know, shuttled, is that shuttle reusable? Or like, how does that work? Yeah. So they do the Falcon 9. So it comes back and lands normally on the barge. So they go up, launch it in the second stage, the top part of the rocket as a fan go up. And they don't relaunch that. That's the new thing, the really big one that they make a big deal out of Texas, the starship and the booster that goes with that.
那么当星链卫星被运送时，航天飞机是可重复使用的吗？或者它是怎么运作的？是的，他们用的是猎鹰9号。它会返回并正常降落在驳船上。他们发射它，第二级火箭，也就是火箭的顶部部分会飞上去。他们不会重新发射那一级。现在他们在大力宣传德克萨斯州那个新的、非常大的东西，即星舰和配套的助推器。
The full thing is supposed to be reusable. So that's like where they see the future. But for now, the first stage, which has most of the, you know, more of the rocket engines and everything. basically goes up and then comes back in lands and those are the videos you see. And so that's why they're able to put, well, part of why they're able to put so many satellites up in orbit.
整个装置应该是可重复使用的。这就是他们眼中的未来。但目前，拥有大部分火箭发动机的第一级基本上会飞上去，然后回来着陆，这就是你看到的那些视频。这就是为什么他们能够将这么多卫星送入轨道的部分原因。
But they still, there is some portion of the launch vehicle that doesn't get reused. Got it. Makes sense. Cool. All right. My second news story is the introduction of the apps in chat GBT and the chatGBT apps SDK.
但他们仍然有一部分运载火箭是无法重复使用的。明白了，有道理。酷。好的，我的第二个新闻是ChatGPT插件和ChatGPT插件SDK的推出。
I feel like this is really powerful. I feel like there's something here. So just to explain at least how I think of it, because it's still very early, basically, and I don't have a lot of details on it yet, I don't think they even kind of have a lot of details yet themselves. But the way I imagine this working is, let's say you ask chat GPT to play your favorite song, or you ask it to buy eggs from... I guess if you say from let's say buy eggs from Walmart right so right now if you do that
我觉得这非常强大。我觉得这里面大有可为。简单解释一下我的想法，因为现在还处于早期阶段，我还没有太多细节，我想他们自己可能也没有太多细节。但我设想的工作方式是，假设你让ChatGPT播放你最喜欢的歌，或者你让它从……假设你说从沃尔玛买鸡蛋，那么现在如果你这样做，
you know chat GPT is going to say hey I can't do any of these things would you like me to do something else it's always so polite it's like would you like me to just talk to you about eggs but you know in the future with these apps you will install the Walmart app
你知道ChatGPT会说：“嘿，我做不到这些，你想让我做点别的吗？”它总是那么礼貌，就像“你想让我和你聊聊鸡蛋吗？”但在未来，有了这些插件，你将安装沃尔玛插件，
and when you ask a question you know the opening I folks will figure out from your question whether they should route that question to an app or not. And if they decide they should, it gets routed and now Walmart, you know, which probably is using ChachyPT
当你问问题时，OpenAI的人会根据你的问题判断是否应该将其路由到插件。如果他们决定应该，它就会被路由，现在沃尔玛——它可能已经在用ChatGPT了——
anyways, but like now Walmart gets your question and they're poised to handle it differently. So for example, if Walmart gets your question, they could order the eggs. They have your identity from you being logged into Chatchee. And so they can order the eggs and eggs show up at your house the next day, which is pretty cool. I do feel like this is kind of like a new kind of app store moment, which is pretty exciting.
总之，现在沃尔玛收到了你的问题，他们准备以不同的方式处理它。例如，如果沃尔玛收到你的问题，他们可以订购鸡蛋。他们有你登录ChatGPT时的身份信息，所以他们可以订购鸡蛋，第二天鸡蛋就会送到你家，这太酷了。我确实觉得这就像是一个新的应用商店时刻，非常令人兴奋。
I do feel like we'll kind of look back on this and say, oh, like, I wish I'd built like the, you know, whatever the most obvious app is, maybe groceries is it, I don't know. But I feel like now is the time to think about, like, what is the app that obviously everybody wants? Because apps aren't even allowed on the store yet. I think they're going to announce a date when you can start submitting apps. But you have access to the SDK. So if you have something where you think chat would be a better experience than going on the web or whatever else you would do, now is the time to build that thing so that as soon as they announced a,
我确实觉得我们回头看时会说：“哦，我真希望我当时开发了那个最明显的应用，也许是杂货类，我不知道。”但我感觉现在是时候思考什么应用是每个人都显然需要的了。因为插件商店还没开放，我想他们会宣布一个可以开始提交插件的日期。但你现在可以访问SDK。所以如果你觉得在某些场景下，聊天比上网或其他方式体验更好，现在就是构建它的时机，这样一旦他们宣布提交流程，你就能排在第一位。我确实认为这里面有极其强大的东西。当它发布时，我看到标题写着“一个PPT杀死了上千家初创公司”之类的。
the submission process you could be first in line. I do think there's something just extraordinarily powerful here. When this was launched, I saw it was like a thousand startups are killed by one slide or something.
标题是这样的。但我猜，我喜欢你解释的方式，如果你开发你的应用，就像现在你可以托管自己的服务器，如果你做一些本地化的东西，你的聊天机器人。
It was like the headline. But I guess maybe, I like the way you explain it, I guess, if you develop your app, it's sort of like now you can host your own like server if you do something local and your chat chip.
你的聊天代理可以查询你的本地服务器来回答问题，所以就像是聊天，你做一些训练或上传一些工作流，然后OpenAI会在内部将ChatGPT查询路由到那里。如果你在那里托管了东西，比如你在他们的生态系统中，你可以运行任意代码吗？这还不完全清楚。是的，让我试着解释一下：想法是，你提交一个插件，OpenAI批准它，现在你在他们的应用商店里了。所以一个使用ChatGPT的人安装了你的插件，对吧？现在，当那个人向OpenAI提问时，
Your chat agent can query your you know local server there's answering something so it's like sort of chat you do some training or upload some workflow or something and then open ai will route chat gpt queries to that internally if you host something there like if you is a state in their ecosystem can you run arbitrary code so it's not completely clear yeah let me let me see if like to explain it so the idea is you know you you submit an app uh open a i approves it now you're on their app store right So a person who uses chat GPT installs your app, right? Now, when that person asks questions to OpenAI,
OpenAI可以将其中一些问题路由给你。然后你可以使用OpenAI来帮助回答问题，但他们现在期望你用答案来回应。所以就像你说的，如果你是一家杂货店，你确保你的OpenAI插件知道如何调用你的库存和定价REST API。
OpenAI can route some of those questions to you. And you could then use OpenAI as part of helping answer the question, but they're now expecting you to respond with an answer. So in the case, like you said, So you're a grocery store. You do work to make sure that, like, your OpenAI app knows how to call your inventory and pricing, you know, Rest API.
你把所有这些信息提供给你的子组件插件。然后用户安装它，这就是为什么它不需要在应用商店的所有插件中进行消歧。好的，我想是对的。你也可以构建我之前提到的Pydantic AI那样的工具。除了开放式地让ChatGPT用一串文本调用你之外，你还可以有一个工具。
And so you give all of that information or whatever to your subcomponent app. And then, okay, and then the user installs that one, which is why it doesn't have to disambiguate across every app on the app store. Okay. Yeah, I think that's right. And so you can also build tools like I talked about with the Pidentic AI. So in addition to being so open-ended that ChatGBTGBT just calls you with a string of text, you can also have a tool.
例如，也许你有一个“购买杂货”工具，该工具接收一些非常具体的结构化数据。比如杂货的名称、数量等等。我的意思是，你仍然必须自己做所有的验证，因为你永远不知道ChatGPT会用什么来调用你的工具，但至少这可能比你只得到一串文本然后必须弄清楚该怎么做要结构化得多。太酷了。是的，一定要看看这个。我的意思是，我觉得大家，特别是如果你是业余爱好者，我觉得这是一个尽早参与的好机会。是的，我想这就是应用商店里那十几个放屁应用在苹果应用商店第一年赚了那么多钱的原因。
So for example, maybe you have a buy groceries tool and that tool takes like some very specific structured data. So like the name of the grocery and what quantity and all of that. I mean, you still have to do all the validation yourself because you don't never know what ChatGBTGT is going to call your tool with, but at least that might be more structured than, you know, you just have a string of text and have to figure out what to do with that. Very cool. Yeah, definitely check this out. I mean, I feel like folks out there, you know, especially if you're a hobbyist, this is like something to get in on early, I feel. Yeah, I guess that's the what the dozen fart apps on the app store that made. you know, tons of money in the first year of the Apple App Store.
是的，没错。你需要一个等价物，ChatGPT，我试着把它做成“放屁GPT”，我不知道，放屁GPT，好吧，不，这会演变成……我们别这么做。ChatGPT。哦，停下，停下。天哪。好吧，我们进入节目推荐环节。我们得去掉“友好”标签或者其他什么“适合工作”的标签。
Yeah, yeah, exactly. You need the equivalent, the chart GPT, chat, I try to make it chart, fart, GPT, I don't know, fart GPD, okay, oh, no, my, this is going to evolve, let's not do it. Chart GPT. Oh, stop, stop. Oh, boy. All right, let's just move to book at the show. We'll have to get rid of the friendly tag or whatever, the safer work tag.
我不知道我们有没有友好标签，不管怎样，我的节目推荐，直接硬转折。过渡，强行过渡，是，我重复一遍，《众志》（The Will of the Many），我几集前提到过这本书。我当时才刚开始看。我已经读完了。它真的很好。我真的很喜欢它。所以我感觉我欠大家一个后续，如果我要把它作为“嘿，我正在读这本书，看起来很有趣”来推荐的话。我确实读完了。它很好。而且第二部快出来了，可能这集播出的时候它就出来了。所以如果你还没开始读这本书，而且从我上次的推荐听起来很有趣的话，我想我可以再推荐一次，但总之，它肯定有一个
I don't know we have a friendly, no, anyways, my book of the show, just hard pivoting. Segway, forcing a segue, is, I'm repeating, The Will of the Many, I had this book, I believe a couple episodes ago. I had only just started it. I have finished it. It was really good. I really like it. So I felt like I owed the people the like follow up that if I was going to pitch it as a, you know, hey, I'm starting this book. It seems kind of interesting. I did finish it. It is good, you know. And the second one comes out, probably by the time this episode's out, it'll it'll sort of be out so if you haven't started this um book and it sounded interesting from my last pitch i guess i could repitch it but anyways so uh you know definitely has like an
类似魔法系统的东西，一个松散的魔法系统，人们可以贡献一种叫做“意志”的东西，就像他们生命能量的一部分，我猜还没完全解释清楚，他们可以把它给别人，这些意志被汇集到政府中，形成一种等级制度，一个金字塔，这完全是关于那种动态和政治的。当然，这是一个关于一个孤儿男孩的故事，他最终被卷入了阴谋和神秘之中，所有这些好东西。作者是詹姆斯·伊斯林顿（James Islington），我之前推荐过他的其他书。
equivalent of kind of a magic system a loose magic system um where people can uh sort of seed their something called like a will like sort of part of their like energy their life energy i guess isn't hasn't been you know fully explained yet and they can sort of give it to somebody else, and those are assembled into the government in a kind of form of a hierarchy, a pyramid, and it's all about sort of the dynamics, the politics of that. And so, of course, you know, a story about a boy who's an orphan and ends up getting, you know, sucked up into intrigue and mystery and all of that good stuff. But by the author James Islington, who I've recommended other books from before.
这绝对是我现在读完后会推荐的书。我很期待下一本。我想我本可以把它作为我的节目推荐。但下一本看起来也会非常好，我很期待阅读它。好的，我肯定会去看看。我需要多读点小说。
Definitely something that I would recommend now having finished it. And I'm looking forward to the next one. I guess I could have made in my book of the show. But the next one seems like it's going to be really good as well. And I'm looking forward to reading that. All right. Yeah, I'll definitely have to check that out. I need to get more into reading fiction.
我的节目推荐其实是一个播客节目。我在蚕食我们自己的节目。但基本上，我有一段很长的车程。长话短说，就是我和我的两个儿子，我们开车去休斯顿往返。他们在那玩任天堂Switch或者做他们想做的事。所以我心想，我要听个播客。我听完了这个长达六小时的播客，嘉宾是DHH，
My book of the show is actually a podcast episode. I'm cannibalizing our show here. But basically, I had a long drive. So, long story short, it was just me and the boys, me and my two sons, and we were driving to Houston and back. And, you know, they're playing, you know, Nintendo Switch or whatever they want to do. So I'm like, I'm going to listen to a podcast. And I listened to the whole six hours of this podcast with DHS,
就是开发Ruby on Rails的那个人。我觉得这非常迷人。我进去的时候心想，好吧，这是我听说过的人。我的一个朋友告诉我我们应该请DHH上我们的节目。那会很酷。DHH，如果你碰巧在听，虽然我怀疑，或者有认识他的人，我完全愿意。
who's the person who made Ruby on Rails. I thought it was fascinating, actually. I kind of went in thinking, well, you know, this is somebody I have kind of heard about. A friend of mine told me we should have DHH on our show. That would be kind of cool. DHS, if you happen to be listening, which I doubt, or somebody who knows him or something, totally down for that.
但我听说过他，我特别记得他发了很多关于“离开云端”的内容，他最终搬到了托管中心。所以，我觉得这会很有趣，但我老实说，对任何一个只有一个人基本上说了六个小时的播客节目，我的期望值有点低。
But, you know, I'd heard of him, and I remember specifically him posting a lot of, about getting off of the cloud and he ended up moving to like a colo. So, you know, I thought it would be kind of interesting, but I had honestly a little bit low expectations
但我实际上被震撼了。我觉得内容非常有趣。
of just any podcast episode where it's just kind of a one-sided where the person just basically talks for six hours. But I was like blown away, actually. I felt like the content was really interesting.
实际上，它真的违背了很多你经常看到的常见主题。例如，DHH非常鄙视去任何办公室，
actually the whole it really goes against a lot of the sort of like common themes that you're seeing a lot of. So for example DHH like despises going into any office
所以他说远程工作是唯一的工作方式。这是一个非常有趣的视角。他谈到了如何让远程工作运作良好，他已经这样做几十年了，对吧？所以他对此提供了很多见解。
and so he's like remote work is the only work it's a really interesting perspective you know he talks about how to make remote work work well he's been doing this for like decades right So he gives a lot of perspective on that.
这家公司，我想叫37 Signals，他们拿了0美元的融资。所以他们基本上是通过做合同工作来白手起家的。他们做合同工作直到有足够的钱。我想他们可能以一种可以共享知识产权的方式组织了合同工作。最终开源了知识产权，它就变成了Ruby on Rails等等。所以0美元
The company, which I think is called 27 Signals, they took $0 of funding. So they basically bootstrapped themselves by doing contract work. So they did contract work until they had kind of enough money. And I guess maybe they structured the contract work in such a way where they could share the IP. And then eventually open source the IP and it became really. Ruby on Rails and all of that. So $0
的风险投资，0美元的外部投资。他说了一些很有趣的话。他说，人们给我找麻烦，因为他们说，好吧，你们的产品，
of venture, $0 of anyone investing. And he said something kind of interesting. He said, you know, people gave me a hard time because they say, well, you know, you, so their product, which
我忘了名字，哦，Basecamp。所以他们的产品是Basecamp，类似于Jira。人们说，看，你本可以做出Jira。你的产品在很多方面其实比Jira更好，Atlassian是一家巨头公司，而你们是一家小公司。
I forgot the name, oh, base camp. So their product is base camp, which is similar to Jira. And people say, look, you could have made Jira. You know, your product is is actually like in many ways better than Jira and Atlasin is like a giant company and you're this tiny company.
他的回应很有趣。基本上是说，这是一家小公司，但我拥有它的一半。而且Jason，他的联合创始人，拥有另一半。实际上，拥有一家小公司50%的股份
And his response is interesting. It's basically like it's a tiny company but you know, I own half of it. And like Jason, who's his co-founder, owns the other half. And actually like owning 50% of a tiny company
太棒了。我有足够的钱，诸如此类。这真的有点像，我一直想用“苦行僧”这个词，但这确实与你在社交媒体上看到的一切完全背道而驰。社交媒体上的一切都是，
is awesome. And I have more than enough money and all of that. And it was like a real kind of like, I guess like it is also like I keep wanting to think of the word monastic, but it is kind of like totally antithetical to everything you see on social media. Everything on social media is,
“看我们筹集了这笔大额资金。”从来没有人说，“看我们筹集了3000万美元，我们不得不放弃70%的公司。”从来没有人说那部分，对吧？而且每个人似乎都在宣扬亲临现场的美德。
look at this big round we raise. No one ever says, look at this $30 million we raise. We only had to give up, you know, 70% of the company. Like no one ever says that part of it, right? And everyone seems to be just like stolling all the virtues of being in person.
是的，我觉得能有不同的视角，真是令人大开眼界。所以我强烈推荐大家去听。另外，我爸爸是赛车手，所以他花了一两个小时谈论赛车，这让我感同身受，我很喜欢听。那是更私人的事情。但我发现整个采访都很迷人，我强烈推荐大家去看看。有六个小时，所以我认为它算是一本书。
And yeah, I feel like just to have a different perspective, it was pretty mind-blowing. So I highly recommend folks listen to it. Also, my dad was a race car driver, so he spends about an hour or two talking about race car driving, which hits close to home, which I loved hearing about. That's more of a personal thing. But I found the whole interview fascinating, and I'd highly recommend folks check it out. It's six hours, so I think it counts as a book.
有道理。是的，我想37 Signals是私有的。我之前查过，我刚才又看了一下，但我想私有与公开之间有趣的事情之一是，正如你所说，他们不仅有更多的描述，而且不需要分享大量信息并因决策而受到评判。因为没有投资者，
Fair enough. Yeah, I think 37 signals is private. I've looked before, I was just looking again to see, but I guess one of those interesting things about private versus public, and to your point, not only they have a lot more description, like it just don't have to share a lot of information and get judged about decisions. And so because it doesn't have investors or all of this,
甚至人们在Hacker News上发帖，他们只是说，我们能估计他们有多少订阅者、赚多少钱吗？人们在抛出数字，但它们都是猜测，或者基于某种推测，它们不准确。想到这会给一个人带来多少压力减轻，这很有趣，只要说我们只是要做出决定，我们能继续支付员工工资吗？我们能
like even people, you know, here are some hacker news posts, and they're just saying like, can we even estimate how many subscribers they have, how much money? And people are like throwing out numbers, but they're all, you know, just speculation. or you know based on some you know sort of swag at it like they're not accurate and it's just kind of interesting to think about like the amounts of stress reduction that would give to someone to say we just going to make the decision can we continue to pay the people who work for us can we
继续赚我们满意的钱吗？总有那个问题，什么是“足够”？如果你对什么是足够没有答案，那么也许你最终会陷入追求权力、名声和财富的怪圈。这也没关系，我想，但如果你能说，这就够了，他说，我可以做这些很酷的事情，开赛车，拥有一个不会让我讨厌生活的生意。那么，这太棒了。很高兴看到，正如你所说，除了只有一种方式之外，还有另一种方式。是的。我的意思是，有人说，主持人说，你知道，远程工作的一件事是，它有点孤独。
continue to make money that we're happy with and like there's always that question like what's enough you know and like if you don't have an answer to what's enough then maybe you just end up in one of these quests to, you know, seek power and fame and fortune. And that's okay, I guess, but if you can say, this is enough and he is saying, you know, I can do these really cool things, drive race cars and have this business that doesn't make me hate my life. Then, you know, that is awesome. It's great to see, like you said, sort of another way instead of it only, that there's only one way. Yeah. I mean, somebody said, uh, uh, the, the, the host, uh, the podcast said, You know, hey, one thing about working remote is, you know, it's kind of lonely.
你怎么处理这个问题？你怎么结识人？那个人，DHH说，结婚，组建家庭。他说，是的，我有孩子在屋里跑来跑去。我从不感到孤独。你知道，这些就是那种，只是一个不同的视角。我从来没听过任何人给出那样的答案。而且，它太不同了。我还是很诚实。我的意思是，我们刚从休斯顿回来，所以我没有太多时间真正消化这个。但这确实是一个如此不同的视角，我必须认真思考。但我认为那里绝对有智慧的结晶。而且我确实觉得，我在办公室和远程之间来回切换，
How do you deal with that? How do you meet people? And the guy was like, DHH is like, get married, have a family. He's like, yeah, I have kids running around the house. I'm never lonely. You know, it's like, these are the kind of things that like, just like, just a different perspective. Like, I've never heard anyone give any answer like that. And, you know, it's so different. I'm still honest. I mean, we just got back from Houston, so I haven't had a lot of time to really, like, sleep on this. But it's such a different perspective that I have to really think about it. But I think there's definitely nuggets of wisdom there, absolutely. And I do feel like, you know, I've kind of ping ponged between, you know, I was in the office.
新冠疫情爆发了。我远程工作了四年。现在我过去一年都在办公室。我确实觉得，远程在很多方面更好，但它必须做得正确，而且你必须处于正确的情况下。所以我认为，我认为有办公室且90%的人都在里面的远程工作，这很难。当然，你可以让它运作，但我认为在社交上，这需要很多努力，你必须非常积极地管理它。我认为每个人都远程或者都在办公室，你知道，你反正一直都在Zoom上，因为总有……好吧，这是我的视角。
COVID hit. I worked remote for, what, four years. Now I've been in the office of the past year. And I do actually feel like, I feel like remote is better in many ways, but it has to be done correctly and you have to be in the right situation. So I think, I think remote where there is an office and like 90% of the people are in it, I think that's hard. Of course, you can make it work, but I think socially, like, it takes a lot of, you have to be very active on managing that. I think remote where everyone's remote or in the office, you know, it's, it's, um, you're on Zoom all the time anyways, because there's always, this is, okay, this is, this is my perspective.
每个人都远程。每个人都远程。因为你去办公室，但有西雅图办公室，或者有远程的Bob。一旦你有一个以上的办公室，或者公司里有一个人是远程的，现在你就是远程的。因为你反正整天都在Zoom上。我想我的想法和之前说的一样。我不认为有一种正确的方式。我认为正如你所说，这是情境化的。因公司而异，因人而异。有些人讨厌在家，太吵了。其他人说，我受不了办公室，太吵了。人们随时会打断你。对于几乎任何陈述，都会有人从正面和负面角度说出同样的陈述。
Everyone's remote. Everyone's remote. Because you go into the office, but there's the Seattle office or there's Bob who's remote. Like as soon as, as soon as you have more than one office or a single person in the company who's remote, now you're remote. Because you're on. on Zoom all day anyways. I guess my thought here is similar to what I was saying before. I don't think there's one right way. I think to your point, it's situational. It's company by company. It's person by person. Some people hate like, I couldn't be at home. It's noisy. Other people are like, I can't stand the office. It's noisy. People dropping in on you. Like it's, you know, for almost any statement, someone will say the same statement in positive and negative light.
所以像任何事情一样，我的想法是，你必须非常努力地证明有一个单一的正确答案，没有细微差别。每当有人说远程工作是最糟糕的，它没有意义，它永远行不通。或者如果有人说，办公室很蠢，它永远行不通。我们都应该……每当你做一个没有回旋余地的陈述时，那些总是最难辩护的，对吧？而且，拜托，这里肯定有一个梯度。而且，如果有一个梯度，我想，我会说即使是完全在办公室的人，拥有我们可以完全远程的设置意味着人们有一些灵活性。
And so like anything, my, how do you want to say? My thought is you're going to have to try really hard to prove that there's a singular right answer and no nuance. Anytime someone comes and says remote work is the worst, it doesn't make sense, it never works. Or if someone says, and the office is dumb, it never works. We should all be. Like whenever you make a statement with no wiggle room, those are always the hardest to defend, right? And it's like, come on, there's got to be a gradient here. And, you know, and if there's a gradient, I think that, you know, I will say even being people fully in the office, having the setup that we could do fully remote means people have some flexibility to do.
如果他们需要请一周假，或者他们需要，我指出过，在家。有很多随机的事情，人们期望你在家等待送货，或者进行某种改进，或者进来，或者其他什么。然后他们改变了日期。所以拥有一些灵活性来处理这些情况是一个净收益，无论你花在办公室还是在家里的比例是多少。是的，完全有道理。
If they need to take a week, a week, they may have taken a sick week or something away or they needed to, you know, I was pointing out, be home. There's so much random stuff where people expect you to be at your place of living for delivery or for some improvement or to come in or whatever. and then they change the date. So having some flexibility to handle those situations has been a net benefit, regardless of sort of what percentage allocation you spend office or at home. Yeah, totally makes sense.
好的。节目工具。哦，天哪，我觉得我要失声了。这不好。好的。我的是一个游戏，而且我几乎确定我之前推荐过，因为我没查，我不想知道。
All right. Tool of the show. Oh, man, I think I'm losing my voice. It's not good. All right. Mine is a game, and it's a game I am almost certain I didn't look because I didn't want to know, but I'm almost certain that I've recommended before.
每个人都知道它。每个人都有它，但我不在乎，因为我又被吸进去了。我本来自由了，然后我不再自由了。我又在玩《异星工厂》（Factorio）了。甚至不是，虽然它看起来很棒，甚至不是“太空时代”DLC。我只是回到玩原版、基础、无模组的《异星工厂》。我一直在Switch上玩，它总是有点尴尬。在PC上用键盘玩要好得多。
Everyone knows it. Everyone has it, but I don't care, because I got sucked back in. I was free, and then I am no longer free. I've been playing factorial again. And not even, although it looks amazing, not even the Space Age DLC. I'm just back to playing vanilla, bass, no mod, Factoria. I've been playing it on my Switch, and it has been, it's always like a little awkward. It's so much better on the PC with the keyboard.
我会承认，但一旦你进入状态，比如在飞机上，我最近几次就是这样，你知道，可以和家人坐在沙发上，当我在看某个节目时，你真的不想连续第五次看同一个节目，不管怎样。总之，如果你能引用那个节目，而且你知道儿童节目接下来会发生什么，你知道你看得太多次了，这意味着他们看得比你还多，因为你知道你并没有在他们每次看的时候都看。总之，我又被《异星工厂》吸进去了。如果你没玩过它，你要么会认为它要么是工作，要么是神奇的，要么你不会理解它，我想这是三种结果。要么觉得“这就像工作，太烂了，我不想工作”，要么你会觉得“我不明白，这很奇怪，这不好玩”，要么你会觉得“什么？”，你会花10个小时，然后你完全不知道发生了什么。你知道，我大约一个月前发帖说，我有一个好朋友，他正试图增加他的Twitter影响力，并积极尝试这样做。他发帖说：“我一个月内从1300个粉丝增加到了7000个粉丝。”
I will admit, but once you get into the groove and you're like on an airplane, which I was recently a couple of times, you know, can sit on the couch with the family, you know, when I'm watching some show, you just really don't want to watch for the fifth time in a row, which whatever. Anyways, like, if you can quote the show and like, you know what's going to happen from the kids show, you know you've seen it too many times, which means they've seen it even more than you because you know you haven't watched it every time they've watched it. um anyways i'm sucked back in factoria if you've not played it you either are going to assume it is either going to be work or amazing or you won't understand it i guess those are the three three outcomes be like this is just like work it sucks i don't want to work or you're going to go i don't get it this is like weird and and just like this is not fun or you're going to be like what you're going to spend 10 hours and then you have no clue what happened You know, I posted about a month ago, I had a friend, a close friend who's trying to grow his Twitter presence and just actively trying to do this. And he posted saying, you know, I went from 1,300 followers to 7,000 followers in a month.
这是我做过的事情清单。这是一份清单。我回复说：“我是如何用三年时间从1300个粉丝增加到1300个粉丝的。”然后是一张《异星工厂》的截图。但《异星工厂》太棒了。我的意思是，它太令人满足了。这一定是那种最令人满足的感觉之一，就像建造一个工厂。
Here's a list of things I did. And it was a list of things. And I replied, and I was like, how I went from 1,300 followers to 1,300 followers in three years. and it was a screenshot of Factorio. But Factorio is amazing. I mean, it's so satisfying. It's like got to be one of the most satisfying feelings, like building a factory.
我有一个忏悔。我可能有，我不想看有多少小时。我实际上，也许Switch会追踪。我不知道怎么看。它不像Steam上那样显眼。所以我不知道我玩了多少小时。
I have a confession. I have like a probably, I don't want to look how many hours. I don't actually, maybe the switch does track. I don't know how to look. It's not prominent like on Steam. So I'm not sure how many hours I've played.
我从来没发射过火箭。什么？真的吗？那很糟糕吗？这很糟糕，对吧？我需要去做。这已经变成了一个目标。在我这次停止之前，我必须做到。
I've never launched a rocket. What? Really? Is that bad? It's bad, right? I need to do it. It's become like a goal. Like I, before I stop this time, I have to do it.
我总是做其他事情。我只是，我不知道。哇，那太神奇了。实际上，令人惊奇的是，你已经建立了所有这些内在奖励，你知道？就像，哦，我能，给我举一个你花了很长时间但不是火箭的例子。不，不是。不，不，比那更糟。我玩了一会儿。
I just always do other stuff. I just, I don't know. Wow, that's amazing, though. Actually, it's amazing that, like, you have built all these intrinsic rewards, you know? It's like, oh, can I, like, well, give me an example of something that took you a long time that wasn't rocket. No, it's not. No, no, it's worse than that. I play for a while.
我开始达到，就像，它总是到达某个地方，而且总是有点不同，你需要，就像，做一大堆没有良好进展的事情，这样你就可以像早期游戏那样进展，我想我每次都在进步，然后我离开了一段时间，我想我没有时间投入去加倍我的产量，建造另一个这样的东西，或者让蓝图工作，或者让机器人运行，所以我只是把它放下一段时间，或者我忙起来，然后我回来，我不记得任何东西在哪里了，所以我只是开始一个新游戏，然后我只是像重新开始，我只是像带着所有的改进，所以这就像你说的“润滑槽”，只是不断地一遍又一遍地玩早期游戏。
I start to get to, like, and it reaches, like, there's always someplace and it's always a little different where it, you need to, like, do. a bunch without like a good progression so you can like progress early game progress and I'm getting better I think actually each time and then I go away for a while I'm like I don't have time to invest to like double my output here build another one of these or you know get a blueprint working or get the bots going so I just like I put it away for a while or I get busy and then I come back I'm I don't remember where anything is so I just start a new game and then I just like start over and I just like do with all the improvements so it's just like what do you call like greasing the groove like just keep playing the early game over and over again.
我知道，这有道理。这有道理。这很糟糕。我是个坏人。我需要完成游戏。开发者投入了这么多我甚至还没体验过的东西。我的孩子们在创造模式下玩，你甚至不是一个人。你可以随处建造任何东西，而且是无限的。
I know, that makes sense. That makes sense. It's bad. I'm a bad person. Like, I need to finish the game. There's so much developer put in I haven't even experienced. My kids play with a creative mode where you're not even a person. You could just build anything anywhere and it's unlimited.
你可以在地图上瞬移，他们只是用它建造随机的东西。我关掉了咬人虫。咬人虫在那里，但除非你攻击它们，否则它们不会攻击你，因为……是的，我不知道，这太让人焦虑了，伙计。好吧，你知道，我的意思是，你可能知道这一点，但建筑机器人完全改变了游戏的配置，就像……我的在游戏后期会设置好，我会基本上有印章，可以盖出一整个屏幕的内容，所以它就像……四个机器人端口，一堆这些……
And you kind of like teleport around the map and they just build random things with it. I turn the biters. Like the biters are there, but they won't attack you unless you attack them because. yeah i just i don't know it's too anxiety inducing man well you know i mean you probably know this but the construction robots just totally changed the profile of the game like uh um like i i i have mine like near the end game mine will be set up where i'll have basically stamps that like stamp an entire screen's worth of content and so it's like uh uh uh uh uh like four robob ports a bunch of these like
电力塔，然后一堆太阳能电池板，它就盖下去了，然后因为机器人端口是印章的一部分，你知道，它建造了机器人端口，然后它可以建造下一个印章。
electric towers and then a bunch of solar panels and it just stamps down and then because the robo ports are part of the stamp you know it builds the robo ports and then it can build the next stamp
所以我只是走过这条流，盖上数百个这样的东西，然后我就想，电力搞定了，好吧，我不用在游戏的其余部分考虑电力了。不错，好的，我的工具，哦，请继续。
and so I'll just walk across the stream stamping like hundreds of these and then I'm like done with power it's like okay well I don't have to think about power for the rest of the game nice all right my tool oh go ahead
我这个节目的工具是nip.io，这显然是在工作中惹麻烦的好方法，因为我仍然不知道这是什么。所以这就像……我能看出为什么工作场所不喜欢这个，但我会解释
my tool this show is nip.io which is apparently a great way to get in trouble at work as I still have no clue what this is so this is like I could see why workplaces wouldn't like this but I'll explain
这个工具是什么。所以想法是，有很多地方，你知道，你不能只使用IP地址，你必须使用主机名，所以你最终在代码中写了所有这些东西，比如“哦，如果我是本地的，那么使用这个IP地址，否则使用这个主机名”，或者你最终陷入奇怪的情况，比如如果你在Kubernetes上运行，你知道，那么你想与之交谈的主机就叫“数据库”，你可以像ping数据库一样，你知道，curl数据库，从那个Kubernetes集群中的其他节点。
what the tool is so the idea is there are many places where you know you can't use just an IP address you have to use a host name and so you end up in your code writing all these things like oh if I'm local then use like this IP address otherwise use this host name or you end up in weird situations where like if you're running on Kubernetes you know then the host you want to talk to you is just called database and you can like ping database you know curl database like from the other nodes in in that Kubernetes cluster
但当你不在Kubernetes中运行时，现在它就像，“哦，不，它实际上是localhost。”这变得很混乱，对吧？所以这个nip.io就像一种将任何IP地址转换为DNS的酷方法。基本上你取IP地址，不管它是什么，你知道，1.1.1.1。然后在末尾加上.nip.io。现在你就有了一个DNS，但它会解析到那个确切的IP地址。所以，你知道，你有点信任，
But then when you're not running in Kubernetes, now it's like, oh, no, it's actually a local host. It gets all confusing, right? And so this nip.io is like a cool way to turn any IP address into a DNS. So basically you take the IP address, whatever it is, you know, 1.1.1.1. And then you add dot nip.io at the end. and now you have a DNS, but it's going to resolve to exactly that IP address. So, you know, you're kind of trusting,
我会说，Patrick的工作被封锁的原因可能是你有点信任这些人将该DNS转换为正确的IP地址。所以，你知道，你可能会输入像2.2.2.2.2.9.0.9.0.0.0.0.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.，因为那个网站背后的人建立了一个做这件事的DNS查找。但他们明天可以改变那个代码。他们可以让一切.nip.io都指向谷歌，或者指向一个基于网络的比特币矿工，或者其他什么。所以这是一种你承担的漏洞。
I will say that for the reason probably is blocked for Patrick, Patrick's job is that you're kind of trusting these people to convert that DNS to the correct IP address. So, you know, you might put in like 2.2.2.2.2.9.0.9.0.0.0.0.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2. because the people behind that website have built like a DNS lookup that does that. But they could change that code tomorrow. They can make it so everything.nip.io goes to Google or goes to a web-based Bitcoin miner or whatever. So that is sort of a vulnerability that you're taking on.
它是由一家看起来相当有信誉的公司驱动的，但那是一个风险。但当你做调试工作时，特别是在你的笔记本电脑上本地调试，或者你开始一个新项目时，它可能是一个简单
It is, you know, it's powered by a company that seems like pretty reputable. but that is a risk. But when you're doing debugging stuff, especially locally on your laptop or you're getting started with a new project, it could be an easy
方便的工具。是的，这是我的节目工具。但我能看出，是的，就像你说的，有特定的用例，它会非常有用。是的，完全。有很多代码，
kind of convenient. Yeah, that's my tool of the show. But I could see, yeah, like you said, there are specific use cases where it would be really useful. Yeah, totally. There's a lot of code,
我的意思是，特别是第三方代码，期望一个域名，它就是不接受IP地址。这是一种绕过它的方法。好的，所以……哦，请继续。不，不，我只是……总之，工作流编排器，我们要用工作流编排器来编排这个节目。我今天分心了，伙计，我们只是……就像……它就在这里……所以……所以好的。
I mean, especially third-party code that expects a domain name that just will not take an IP address. And this is a way to get around it um all right so oh go ahead no no no i just yeah anyways workflow orchestrator we're gonna orchestrate the show here with a workflow orchestrator i'm distracted today dude we're just like i just like it's like it's like it's like it's like it's like it's like it's up over here um so so okay
我的意思是，特别是那些需要域名却不接受IP地址的第三方代码。这是一种绕过它的方法，嗯，好的，所以，哦，你先请，不不不，我只是，是的，无论如何，工作流编排器，我们要用工作流编排器来编排这个节目，伙计，我今天分心了，我们就像，我只是觉得，就像，就像，就像，就像，就像，就像，就像它就在这边，嗯，所以，所以好的
Let's talk about why you need a workflow orchestrator. So here's a very simple example. And actually kind of spoiler alert, I actually asked this as my interview question. So if you ever end up getting interviewed by me, you're going to probably get this question. Let's say you're building YouTube. And specifically, like, don't worry about like the social networking
我们来谈谈为什么你需要一个工作流编排器。这里有一个非常简单的例子。其实算是个剧透，我面试时经常问这个问题。所以如果你以后被我面试，很可能会遇到这个问题。假设你正在开发 YouTube。具体来说，不用担心社交网络之类的功能，
or anything of that, but just, you know, you upload a video, it turns, transcodes your video a hundred different ways for mobile and, you know, low bandwidth and all of that. And then when other people go to that URL, they get your video. So, um, video is maybe not the best example of this because it takes a while to upload the video. But, you know, you, you upload the video and, um, you know, then it has to go through and do a whole bunch of work, right? That transcoding of that video to other formats, maybe you uploaded it as a quick time video, which they don't want to serve that on the web, right? So that is a time-intensive
或者其他类似的东西，就假设你上传了一个视频，系统会将其转码成一百种不同的格式，以适配移动设备、低带宽环境等等。然后当其他人访问该 URL 时，他们就能看到你的视频。嗯，视频可能不是最好的例子，因为上传视频需要一些时间。但是，你知道，你上传了视频，然后它必须经过一系列处理，对吧？将视频转码为其他格式，比如你上传的是 QuickTime 视频，但网站不想直接提供这种格式，对吧？所以这是一个耗时的
process. And so it's not practical to like just have someone wait on a web request, right? Because if that person just hits F5 or something and closes the connection, you know, how is that going to work, right? Those kind of two problems here. Problem number one is sometimes you have to do things that take a long time. And then problem number two is sometimes you have to do things that are kind of non-interactive where someone will leave and you need this thing to keep working and eventually report back in some way. And the last category of why you'd need this would be, you know, you have a lot of things, a huge batch of things that you need to do. So for example, actually, this is a very real example for us.
过程。因此，让用户在网页请求中等待是不现实的，对吧？因为如果那个人按了 F5 或者关闭了连接，那该怎么办呢？这里有两个问题。第一个问题是，有时你必须做一些耗时很长的事情。第二个问题是，有时你必须做一些非交互式的事情，用户可能会离开，而你需要这个任务继续运行，并最终以某种方式反馈结果。最后一个你需要它的原因是，你有很多任务，一大批任务需要处理。比如，这其实是我们遇到的一个非常真实的例子。
I went through and re-ost-transcribed all of the episodes of programming Throwdown. So if you look at the transcriptions, they're better than they were before. The old system I was using was massively out of date, and I felt like, well, since I upgraded it, I might as well just re-transcribe everything. And so, you know, we have 180-some-odd episodes. 184 episodes. And so that actually is expensive, but even if it wasn't, it's, you know, a batch job that I have to just submit a hundred of these and just tell me when they're all done, right? So that's the basic reason why you'll want to use a workflow orchestrator.
我重新转录了《Programming Throwdown》的所有剧集。如果你看现在的转录稿，它们比以前好多了。我之前使用的旧系统已经严重过时了，我觉得既然升级了，不如把所有内容都重新转录一遍。我们有 180 多集，确切地说是 184 集。这确实成本很高，但即使成本不高，这也是一个批处理作业，我只需要提交这一百多个任务，然后等它们全部完成就行了，对吧？这就是你想要使用工作流编排器的基本原因。
under the hood they all work more or less the same way so there's you know a set of message cues and so i think we've talked about pub sub and these things in the past but basically you know you need a way to submit uh jobs and um the jobs need a way to read your submission and so there needs to be some kind of cue to handle that um if the job is multi-step then when the first step is done now you know, a new thing needs to be pushed onto this message queue saying, okay, we're ready for the second step, right? A job can fail, you know, like AWS could shut down that machine, the hard drive could fail on that machine, etc., etc.,
在底层，它们的工作方式大同小异，都有一些消息队列。我想我们过去讨论过发布/订阅（pub-sub）之类的东西，但基本上，你需要一种提交作业的方法，而作业需要一种读取你提交内容的方法，所以需要某种队列来处理。如果作业是多步骤的，那么当第一步完成时，需要向消息队列推送一条新消息，说“好的，我们可以进行第二步了”，对吧？作业可能会失败，比如 AWS 可能会关闭那台机器，或者那台机器的硬盘可能会损坏等等。
and so message cues are important for, there's a lot of logic around, basically you send a keep alive to the queue while you're still alive, and if the queue doesn't get a keep alive for some amount of time, that you specify, let's just say 10 minutes, it assumes that you're dead and it will rerun, like it will ask another machine to go and process that. Okay, so message queues, a big part of it.
所以消息队列很重要，因为有很多逻辑是围绕着它展开的。基本上，只要你还在运行，就会向队列发送“保持连接”（keep-alive）信号。如果队列在指定时间内（比如 10 分钟）没有收到信号，它就会认为你已经挂了，然后会重新运行，或者要求另一台机器去处理它。好的，所以消息队列是其中很大的一部分。
And containerization, another really big part of it, because you need a way to define some task on your computer, but then ultimately send that task out to the cloud, and there might be hundreds, maybe thousands, tens of thousands of machines kind of running your task. So it's not practical to like sudo app to get install some package all those times. So there needs to be some type of containerization. And then also the workflow, so the thing that, you know, tells, you know,
容器化也是非常重要的一部分，因为你需要一种方法在你的电脑上定义某个任务，然后最终将该任务发送到云端，那里可能有成百上千，甚至成千上万台机器在运行你的任务。所以每次都去 sudo apt-get install 安装软件包是不现实的。因此需要某种容器化。此外，工作流，也就是告诉
the overall system what tasks need to be run and which ones depend on which other ones, that also needs to be put in the cloud somewhere and containerized. And so that's the second ingredient. And the third and final ingredient is some type of worker pool, some type of, you know, a pool of machines that are ready to do work. And you typically pair this with some type of auto scaling. So you have, especially if you have bursty work. So imagine, well, YouTube is such a multinational thing that this wouldn't happen.
整个系统需要运行哪些任务以及哪些任务依赖于其他任务的东西，也需要放在云端的某个地方并进行容器化。这是第二个要素。第三个也是最后一个要素是某种工作池，也就是一组准备好执行工作的机器。你通常会将它与某种自动扩缩容结合使用。所以，特别是如果你有突发性的工作负载。想象一下，嗯，YouTube 是一个如此庞大的跨国平台，这种情况可能不会发生。
But imagine if you were building a version of YouTube and you're just getting started where it may be way more popular in the U.S., you know, you'd want to scale those nodes down when it's the wee hours in our time zones and then scale them up when it's peak hours. Yeah, I think that becomes important too for, you know, something going viral. So if your website goes viral,
但想象一下，如果你正在构建一个 YouTube 的版本，而且你才刚刚起步，它在美国可能更受欢迎，你会在我们时区的深夜缩减节点，然后在高峰时段扩容。是的，我认为对于某些可能突然爆火的东西来说，这一点也很重要。所以如果你的网站爆火了，
you don't, you want to capture the signups. You want to capture whatever, right? So, but I think in that case, if the things people are signing up or doing or kicking off these workflows, I wanted to circle back to, you know, talking about failures, but I think there's a couple of things maybe that are less obvious or maybe important about these. So one is you were mentioning, you know, something like YouTube size,
你不想错过注册用户。你想抓住一切机会，对吧？但在那种情况下，如果人们注册或操作触发了这些工作流，我想回到刚才关于失败的话题。但我认为还有一些不太明显但可能很重要的事情。一是你提到的 YouTube 规模，
but when you're kind of small, things generally fail because you did something wrong or there's a bug or a problem. But when you reach a certain size, even if, you know, if you look at what I guess is called meantime between failure, like you said, a hard drive or cosmic ray or whatever it may be, But when you're running a million, you know, jobs a day, what is the chance that at least one job is going to, you know, have an issue in a day? It's it's non-trivial, right? It's noticeable. And so you're getting these failures because someone is walking into the server room
但当你规模较小时，事情通常是因为你做错了什么，或者有 bug 或问题而失败。但当你达到一定规模时，即使你关注所谓的“平均故障间隔时间”（MTBF），比如硬盘损坏、宇宙射线或其他什么原因，当你每天运行一百万个作业时，每天至少有一个作业出现问题的概率是多少？这是不可忽视的，对吧？是显而易见的。所以你会遇到这些失败，因为有人走进服务器机房，
and pulling out a server rack and like blowing the dust out of it for maintenance or whatever, right? And you can either have that be very carefully planned or just say, look, it's going to get handled. and I think kind of that is the same vein as you see stuff like I think Netflix was famous for doing chaos monkey something that goes in
拔掉一个服务器机架，为了维护吹掉里面的灰尘什么的，对吧？你可以选择非常仔细地计划，或者干脆说，看，它会被处理掉的。我认为这和 Netflix 著名的“混沌猴”（Chaos Monkey）是同一个思路，它会进入系统，
and just basically kills off nodes or drop nodes to make sure you know nothing nothing breaks it just randomly sows chaos
随机杀死节点或丢弃节点，以确保没有任何东西会崩溃，它只是随机制造混乱。
I think the other thing that was my job when I was there that is my job in my family I'm just chaos monkey oh dad's here
我想另一件事就是我在那里时的工作，也是我在家里的工作，我就是那个“混沌猴”。哦，爸爸来了。
Okay, wow, I've been distracted today. But the other thing is, you know, we were talking about, you know, and I think we'll get to it in a minute, but something like training and LM and it's, you know, $10 million. Some of these workflows could be very, very, very expensive. And like you said, imagine there's some error. But imagine the error occurs at like a very late stage. You don't want to start all the way again from the beginning.
好吧，哇，我今天走神了。但另一件事是，我们刚才谈到的，我想我们一会儿会讲到，比如训练大语言模型（LLM），这需要 1000 万美元。其中一些工作流可能非常、非常、非常昂贵。就像你说的，想象一下出现了错误。但想象一下错误发生在非常靠后的阶段。你肯定不想从头开始。
So being able to kind of, it's not exactly a hot swap, but being able to resume the pipeline with a new, version of like a later node or even you just maybe it's not an error maybe the whole thing finishes but then you realize oh here in this last stage or this last but we could do better or we could do something different so having a system that automatically is like preserving those stages and inputs and and you know that kind of stuff so you can sort of rerun later parts becomes like super useful and tying that all with the dashboard and management which is things I have seen people not use one of these and then you end up just basically reinventing them
所以能够，这不完全是热插拔，但能够用新版本的后续节点恢复流水线，或者即使不是错误，只是整个流程完成了，但你意识到“哦，在最后这个阶段，我们可以做得更好，或者我们可以做点不同的事情”。所以拥有一个能自动保存这些阶段和输入的系统，这样你就可以重新运行后续部分，这变得超级有用。再加上仪表板和管理功能，我见过人们不使用这些工具，结果最后基本上是在重复造轮子。
So you can either like not use them or you can reinvent one with half the features that you like do yourself. And you just slowly try to re and build a crappier version of like an existing solution. Yeah, totally, totally agree. Yeah, I think the part you mentioned about history and backfill is is super important. Like there have been so many times where exactly what you said happens, you know, the job runs successfully, but it wasn't actually a success. Like we actually went the past three days with no art. because, you know, maybe the upload failed, but it didn't let the job know that something was wrong. So, um, so for example, like a very common pattern is where you catch an error
所以你要么不用它们，要么就自己做一个功能减半的版本。你只是慢慢地尝试重新构建一个现有解决方案的糟糕版本。是的，完全同意。是的，我认为你提到的关于历史记录和回填（backfill）的部分非常重要。有很多次，正如你所说的那样，作业运行成功了，但实际上并没有成功。比如我们过去三天没有产出，因为上传失败了，但它没有通知作业出了问题。所以，举个例子，一个非常常见的模式是你在 Python 或任何语言中捕获错误。
in Python or in any language. You catch the error and then log an error message. And that's great in all, but because you caught the error and you didn't bubble it all the way up, now your job thinks it finished successfully. Like if you didn't set the exit code correctly on your program. And so, you know, that can happen and then you find out about it. Even if you find out about it an hour later, if your website's popular enough, that could be millions of jobs that have run in that hour that need to be rerun. So having all of that ledger and then being able to backfill and say, okay, you know, all the jobs from, you know, three days ago to now, I need to rerun all of them and it just goes through and does that and auto scales to handle it all that that's um that's and
你捕获了错误并记录了一条错误消息。这很好，但因为你捕获了错误却没有将其向上抛出，现在你的作业认为它成功完成了。比如如果你没有在程序中正确设置退出代码。所以，这种情况可能会发生，然后你才发现。即使你一小时后才发现，如果你的网站足够受欢迎，那一小时内可能已经运行了数百万个需要重新运行的作业。所以拥有所有的记录，并且能够进行回填，说“好的，从三天前到现在的所有作业，我需要全部重新运行”，它就会自动完成并进行自动扩缩容来处理这一切，这真是……
there's sort of this uh kind of like um you know how cars have the uh what's it um there's basically like a backup system so imagine um so like imagine on your HUD imagine your HUD just like disappears like the the OS powering the heads up display on your car fails it's got some kind of backup where you'll at least see like the miles per hour or something but now that yeah right but that contingency that's where i was thinking of there's a contingent operating system in most of these cars but now that contingent operating system that really needs to not fail right because now you're really host and so similarly here you know the workflow orchestrator itself if it starts failing it's that can be a really difficult thing to survive right
还有一种类似……你知道汽车有那种……怎么说呢……基本上有一个备份系统。所以想象一下，想象你的抬头显示器（HUD）消失了，也就是驱动汽车抬头显示器的操作系统崩溃了，它有一种备份，你至少能看到时速之类的东西。但现在，是的，没错，那种应急系统，大多数汽车里都有一个应急操作系统。但现在那个应急操作系统真的不能再出故障了，因为那样你就彻底完蛋了。所以同样地，工作流编排器本身如果开始崩溃，那将是一个非常难以生存的问题，对吧？
And so to your point, you know, I've seen it as well where people try to build their own. And it happens so innocently, you know, the way it happens is, you know, you have some task. And this happens at big companies, you know, so it's not a small company thing specifically. Like, you have some task and it's relatively minor. And so you have this script that does it. And, you know, that starts to succeed. So it's like, well, you know, I'm just going to make a cron job and have it run this Python script every hour. And then it's like, oh, okay, now I need to run it every minute.
所以回到你的观点，我也见过人们试图自己构建。这种情况发生得很无辜，你知道，发生的方式是，你有一些任务。这在大公司也会发生，所以这不仅仅是小公司的问题。比如你有一个任务，它相对较小。所以你写了一个脚本来完成它。然后，它开始成功运行了。所以你会想，“好吧，我只要写个 cron job，让它每小时运行这个 Python 脚本就行了。”然后变成，“哦，好的，现在我需要每分钟运行一次。”
Oh, now I need like three machines. So I'll just spin up three, C2 instances all running this Python script every minute. And you kind of like, at some point, you have to just eat the technical debt and like set up a workflow orchestrator. But I've seen too many cases where people are going to go too long. And then when there is an issue, it becomes very difficult. I think the other term you'll hear with a lot of these is DAG, which isn't unique to these, but that all of these jobs form a directed ASIC, like, no cycle graph. So they're not looping.
“哦，现在我需要三台机器。”所以我启动了三个 EC2 实例，每分钟都在运行这个 Python 脚本。在某个时刻，你必须承担技术债务，去设置一个工作流编排器。但我见过太多案例，人们拖得太久了。然后当出现问题时，就变得非常困难。我想你还会听到另一个术语，叫 DAG（有向无环图），这并不是这些工具独有的，但所有这些作业都形成了一个有向无环图。所以它们不会循环。
So they have a start. They process some number of jobs with some interdependencies, and then they reach a conclusion. And so you'll hear them talked about that way. Maybe help me there, Jason. So, and not to throw a wrinkle here, but so workflow orchestration versus some that is more seen as like I would call like a pipeline like spark or something. What's the sort of distinction
它们有一个起点。它们处理一定数量的作业，这些作业之间存在相互依赖关系，然后它们得出一个结论。所以你会听到人们这样谈论它们。Jason，在这方面帮帮我。所以，不是要制造麻烦，但工作流编排与更像是流水线的东西（比如 Spark 之类的）有什么区别？它们之间的界限在哪里，还是说界限很模糊？
between or where's a line or is it blurry? Like what's the difference between something that would be viewed as more like pipeline versus workflow orchestration? Yeah, that's a great question. I don't have a easy answer but basically I would say okay, one thing a
或者说，被视为流水线的东西与工作流编排之间有什么区别？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我没有简单的答案，但基本上我会说，有一件事是
workflow orchestrator cannot do is it cannot fuse nodes together. So you kind of explicitly define, like, do this task, do that task, do that task, and they all depend on each other or in a sequence or something. And if tasks like B and C really could be fused into one operation, it won't do that because it makes no assumption about what programming language or what version of Ubuntu is running on that node or anything like that.
工作流编排器做不到的，那就是它不能将节点融合在一起。你必须明确定义：执行这个任务，执行那个任务，执行那个任务，它们都相互依赖，或者按顺序执行。如果任务 B 和 C 真的可以融合为一个操作，它也不会这样做，因为它不对该节点上运行的编程语言或 Ubuntu 版本做任何假设。
They're all just basically Docker containers that are getting spun up. you can actually, depending on the orchestrator you use, some orchestrators have it where you can spin up a container for a particular node, and that container can do multiple tasks. Let's say I have 10 videos. I have to transcode all of them to quick time.
它们基本上都是启动的 Docker 容器。根据你使用的编排器，有些编排器允许你为特定节点启动一个容器，而该容器可以执行多个任务。假设我有 10 个视频。我必须将它们全部转码为 QuickTime。
I have a quick time node, and that node could do all 10 of them. Right. But by default, most of these orchestrators, you actually spin up a Docker container, do that one thing, that one time, and then tear it back down. And so there's a pretty heavy spin-up, spin-down time
我有一个 QuickTime 节点，该节点可以处理所有 10 个视频。没错。但默认情况下，大多数这些编排器会启动一个 Docker 容器，做那一件事情，做完一次，然后将其销毁。所以任务的启动和关闭时间成本相当高。
for tests. Conversely, with Spark, like, you kind of create, you do create sort of a DAG, and same with early versions of PiTorch, or if you do PiTorch.compile, or, you know, early versions of TensorFlow, you would create a DAG of operations, and then what the Spark compiler or Pi Torch compiler
相反，使用 Spark，你确实会创建一个 DAG，PyTorch 的早期版本也是如此，或者如果你使用 PyTorch.compile，或者 TensorFlow 的早期版本，你会创建一个操作的 DAG，然后 Spark 编译器或 PyTorch 编译器
TensorFlow will do is it will fuse operations and it will create this super optimized bag and it does that because all of the operations are within its own ecosystem. So like Spark has a limited vocabulary as does Pi Torch. And so this being so open-ended, it can just run any Docker container with any arguments you want.
TensorFlow 会做的是融合操作，并创建一个超级优化的 DAG，它之所以能这样做，是因为所有操作都在它自己的生态系统内。所以 Spark 的词汇量有限，PyTorch 也是如此。而这种工作流编排器非常开放，它可以运行任何带有你想要的任何参数的 Docker 容器。
that open-endedness comes at a cost. All right, yeah, that makes sense. Cool. So, yeah, quick rundown on the steps to use a workflow orchestrator. Typically, you containerize your tasks. That's usually, you know, pretty straightforward. Most people are using Docker anyways. But you also have to containerize the workflow itself.
这种开放性是有代价的。好的，明白了。酷。那么，使用工作流编排器的步骤简述。通常，你会对任务进行容器化。这通常相当简单。大多数人都在使用 Docker。但你也必须对工作流本身进行容器化。
So the file that says, you know, run this task, and then, uh, run the second task afterwards, like that, that logic has to go somewhere. Um, and so all of these examples that we'll talk about in the future, uh, they all do it differently. Um, and then after that, you're kind of off to the races. You submit jobs. Um, one thing that is, um, that varies a lot from, from orchestrator to orchestrator is how to pass data among the tasks. So, So the early versions of these, the only way you could pass information was through arguments.
所以那个定义“运行这个任务，然后运行第二个任务”的文件，那种逻辑必须放在某个地方。我们将来讨论的所有例子，它们处理的方式都不同。在那之后，你就准备好开始了。你提交作业。有一件事在不同的编排器之间差异很大，那就是如何在任务之间传递数据。
So job one finishes, and then it's allowed to inject some command line arguments into job two. But that's it. And because it's a command line argument, you can't stick like a whole JSON blob in there, a large JSON blob or anything like that. You couldn't put an image in there or something.
所以这些工具的早期版本，传递信息的唯一方法是通过参数。
And so what you have to do for these early ones, is use something else to store everything. So, you know, the task transcodes the video, and then it doesn't pass the transcoded video onto the next task, which may be like sets a flag in a database saying it's ready. But what it does, it puts the transcoded video into some object store, like S3 or something else. And then all it passes to the next task is maybe a unique idea of the video.
所以作业一完成，它被允许向作业二注入一些命令行参数。但仅此而已。因为它是命令行参数，你不能把整个 JSON 数据块塞进去，或者类似的东西。你不能把图片放进去。所以对于这些早期版本，你必须使用其他东西来存储所有内容。所以，任务转码了视频，然后它不会把转码后的视频传给下一个任务（下一个任务可能只是在数据库中设置一个标志，表示它已准备好）。它所做的是把转码后的视频放入某个对象存储中，比如 S3 或其他地方。然后它传给下一个任务的只是视频的唯一 ID。
later versions they allow you to pass arbitrary data but under the hood they're doing the same thing so when you pass like a panda's data frame or an image or something from one task to the other under the hood it's actually storing it an S3 in some temporary bucket which has like a low retention policy
后来的版本允许你传递任意数据，但在底层它们做的是同样的事情。所以当你从一个任务向另一个任务传递 Pandas 数据帧或图像时，底层实际上是把它存储在 S3 的某个临时存储桶中，该存储桶具有较低的保留策略，
and then pulling it back out for the next So, but yeah, that's all there is too. So it's really not that hard. I would say this is in the category of things that kind of like functional programming languages where it's kind of a unique paradigm. If you've never used a workflow orchestrator, it can look very daunting. But once you've learned one, now you kind of can do pretty much all of them pretty easily. I haven't used one, but looking forward, a lot of these names are familiar. So, uh, wait, really?
然后为下一个任务将其拉取出来。所以，这就是全部内容了。所以它真的没那么难。我想说这属于函数式编程语言那一类，它是一种独特的范式。如果你从未使用过工作流编排器，它看起来可能非常令人生畏。但一旦你学会了一个，你基本上可以很容易地使用所有其他的。我没用过，但展望未来，很多名字都很熟悉。等等，真的吗？
You haven't, uh, well, what about like a proprietary one or something? I'm sure you, oh, yeah, uh, I guess that's true, but I feel like it's a bit different. Like if someone else already has like all of this setup, I, I've sort of been a part of one of them, I guess. So other people sets up this stuff and I, you know, define some portion of some code that needs to run and someone is sucking it up into a container and running it. Yeah, that way. But I've never sat down and had to write in the language. of describing the workflow as an example. That makes sense.
你没用过？好吧，那专有的那种呢？我相信你……哦，是的，我想那是真的，但我感觉有点不同。如果别人已经设置好了所有这些，我算是参与过其中之一。其他人设置了这些东西，我定义了需要运行的某部分代码，有人把它塞进容器里运行。是的，是那样。但我从未坐下来必须用描述工作流的语言来编写示例。这说得通。
Yeah, at Meta, we had something called Datastorm, which is very similar to the ones we'll talk about next, but I never worked on Datastorm. I was mainly mostly a customer, but they all are extremely similar. And I think a lot of these cases, like Data Storm's an example, there was something called, flume which was
是的，在 Meta，我们有一种叫 Datastorm 的东西，它和我们接下来要谈的那些非常相似，但我从未在 Datastorm 上工作过。我主要是作为一个用户，但它们都极其相似。我认为在很多情况下，比如 Data Storm 就是一个例子，还有一种叫 Flume 的东西，
similar to Spark kind of a combination of Spark and a workflow orchestrator and then that someone made an open source version of that but yeah I think most people will encounter workflow orchestrators it might just be a homegrown one instead of one of these ones
它类似于 Spark，是 Spark 和工作流编排器的结合体，然后有人做了一个开源版本。但我觉得大多数人会遇到的工作流编排器，可能只是一个自研的，而不是这些现成的。
yeah that's true but the the big the big market share ones are Airflow. Airflow is an Apache project. I don't know the history of Airflow, but it's kind of the 900 pound gorilla
是的，那是真的，但市场份额最大的还是 Airflow。Airflow 是一个 Apache 项目。我不知道 Airflow 的历史，但它在业内就像是一个 900 磅重的大猩猩。所以如果你在 AWS 上，有一种叫 MWAA 的东西，它是托管的。我不知道 W 代表什么，但 A 是 Apache Airflow。基本上，你甚至不需要在任何电脑上自己设置 Airflow，
in the room. So if you're on AWS, there's something called MWAA, which is managed. I don't know what the W is, but the A's are Apache Airflow. And basically, you don't even have to set up airflow yourself on any computer or anything like
他们为你做了一切。这有点像数据库的 RDS。对于 RDS，你不需要自己在一台机器上安装 Postgres。他们对 Airflow 也有同样的服务。Airflow 是遗留系统。它没有我们接下来要谈的其他工具的许多功能。但你可以确信 Airflow 几乎可以做任何事情。
that, they just do everything for you. It's kind of like RDS for databases. So RDS things, you don't have to like install Postgres on a machine yourself or anything like that. They have the same thing for Airflow. Airflow is legacy. It doesn't have a lot of the features of the other ones we'll talk about. But you can feel confident that Airflow can do almost anything.
如果你在 Airflow 中无法完成某件事，那意味着在成千上万的开发者中，没有人尝试过你正在做的事情，这可能是一个信号，说明你做错了。它属于那种“大到不能倒”的类别。但它是遗留系统。我想它最初是用 Java 编写的。因为 Airflow 太开放了，
Like, if you can't get it done in Airflow, what that means is of the thousands and thousands of developers, nobody's tried to do what you're trying to do, which is maybe a sign that you're doing something wrong. It's kind of in that category where too big to fail, I guess. But it is legacy. I think it's originally in Java. And because Airflow is so open-ended,
它没有很好地与任何一种语言挂钩，我认为这是 Airflow 最大的缺点。其他例子，我经常使用 Dagster。Dagster 非常不错。我想它是纯 Python 的，或者如果不是，
you know, it's not hooked into any one language that well, I would say, is my biggest detractive. of Airflow. Some other examples, I used Dagster a lot. Dagster is quite nice. I think it's Python only, or if it's not,
可能有一个 REST API，用起来会很丑，但它确实是为 Python 设计的。它很好，它为你提供了装饰器，所以你可以将函数装饰为 Dagster 节点。当一个函数调用另一个函数时，如果它调用一个 Dagster 节点作为函数，
there's maybe a Rest API that would be pretty ugly to use, but it's really meant for Python. It's nice, it gives you old decorators, so you can decorate functions as Dagster nodes. And so when a function calls another, if it calls a Daxter node as a function,
它会返回一个 future，Dagster 会为你处理所有这些。所以它会暂停你函数的运行，调用那个依赖任务，然后回来，把结果给你，这非常聪明，非常酷。Temporal 刚刚完成了，
it'll return back a future, and Daxter kind of handles all of that for you. So it kind of pauses the operation of your function, calls that dependent task, and then comes back, and gives you your function back, which is pretty clever, pretty cool. So temporal is they actually just raised,
我想是 B 轮融资。我要核实一下。是的，他们筹集了 25 亿美元。哦，25 亿美元是他们的估值。他们完成了 C 轮融资。这非常酷。所以它
I think, a series, B. I'm going to double check. Yeah, they raised $2.5. Oh, $2.5 billion is their valuation. A series C, they raised. And it's pretty cool. So it's
采取了不同的方式。你没有仪表板。你没有我们谈到的很多重要的东西。但它只给你真正重要的核心功能，那就是能够运行一个函数，并且知道你会得到一个答案，
kind of a different take. You don't have the dashboard. You don't have a lot of the things we talked about that are important. But it just gives you the bare thing that really matters, which is being able to run a function and know you're going to get an answer
无论该函数需要多长时间。所以如果你要构建自己的工作流编排器，我认为 Temporal 会是一个很好的构建基础。甚至有可能 Dagster 也在使用 Temporal。这很有可能。但它确实有点像底层，真正持久地调用单个函数。
regardless of how long that function takes. So temporal would be a good thing if you're building your own workflow orchestrator, I think temporal would be a good thing to build it on top of. And it might even be that Daxter uses temporal. It's very possible. But it is kind of like lower level, you know, really calling individual functions durably.
类似于 Temporal，还有 Apache Ray。所以 Ray 来自一家叫 AnyScale 的公司。Ray 也非常底层，所以你是在调用单个函数，而且它必须是 Python 的。
similar to temporal there's Apache Ray so Ray comes from this company called Any Scale Ray is also pretty low level so you're calling individual functions and it has to be kind of in Python
所以它是在非常底层的层面进行挂钩，有点像 Temporal。Ray 真正强大的地方在于它快得令人难以置信。所以使用 Ray，你提前启动所有机器。所以，你知道，所有这些其他工作流编排器，你是在启动一台机器，做一些工作，
and so it's hooking in at pretty low level kind of like temporal the thing that's really powerful about Ray is just how unbelievably fast it is So with Ray, you spin up all the machines in advance. So, you know, all these other workflow orchestrators, you're spinning up a machine, doing some work,
然后将其关闭。使用 Ray，你启动整个集群。当整个集群启动并运行时，你执行一堆函数，这些函数会被分发到你为该特定任务启动的集群中。这是一个完全连接的机器网格，当你完成任务时，
and then spinning it back down. With Ray, you spin up a whole cluster. When that whole cluster is up and running, you then execute a bunch of functions, and those functions get farmed out to that cluster you span up for that particular task you're doing. and so it's a fully connected mesh of machines and then when you finish your task
整个集群会被关闭。所以你前期付出的代价更大，但你得到了超低延迟。一旦整个集群启动，你永远不用担心任何节点需要另一台机器之类的。我有的最后一个例子是 Kubeflow，大家应该了解一下。
that entire cluster gets spun down so you're paying a bigger hit up front but you're getting like super super low latency like you never have to worry once the whole cluster is up you never have to worry about any node requiring another machine or anything like that and the final example I have which folks should know about is cube flow
Kubeflow 在某种意义上类似于 Airflow。最大的区别在于他们集成了一个仪表板，你可以上传不同的统计数据。例如，Airflow 有一个仪表板，你可以监控作业并看到“哦，昨天我有五个失败的作业”。Kubeflow 也有这个，但 Kubeflow 允许你为每次运行提供一个仪表板。所以就像是，“好的，任务三，
cube flow is similar in a sense to Airflow the big difference is they've integrated a dashboard where you can upload different statistics so for example Airflow is a dashboard where you can monitor the jobs and see oh I have five failed jobs yesterday QPlo has that too but QVlow allows you to like each run have a dashboard for that specific run. And so it's like, okay, task three,
输出一个时间序列图，就在这里。”“任务四创建了一个散点图，就在这里。”所以对于产生统计输出的工作流来说，这是一个很棒的功能标签。听起来其中一些，正如你所说，
you know, output a time series graph, and here it is. Task four created a scatter plot, and there it is. And so for workflows that are producing statistical outputs, that's like a nice feature tab. It sounds like some of them are, like you said,
是更底层的。Ray 听起来像是更短，不是更短。你想要更高的响应速度，更低的延迟，你想要能够做很多很多事情，你想要把它们分片并进行分布式处理。而其他东西，比如你说的转码视频之类的，你基本上想要做大量的数据读取，做大量的处理，做大量的数据写入，
sort of lower level. Like Ray sort of sounds like it's shorter, not shorter. You want higher, you know, response lower response times lower latency you want to be able to do lots and lots and lots of things you want to sort of shard them all up and have them sort of distributed and then other things like you were sort of saying like transcoding a video or something you pretty much want to like do a bunch of data reading do a bunch of processing kind of do a bunch of data writing
你知道，就外部而言，所以你是在处理大型二进制对象和非常长的运行时间。所以感觉好像没有一个通用的解决方案可以覆盖所有这些，这我想也是合理的。正如你所说，我认为一个容器是否可以是多用途的，或者你是否真的需要为所有不同的作业准备不同的容器，可能在难易程度上起着巨大的作用。是的，是的，完全同意。这是那种界限有点模糊的事情之一，因为我敢肯定，肯定有人会发邮件告诉我们，“哦，其实你可以在 Airflow 中这样做，或者 Ray 也可以做到。”但总的来说，在基准层面，
you know as far as like externally so you're sort of dealing with large blobbed objects and very long run times and so it feels it feels like there isn't a generic solution that just sort of like meshes over all of it, which I guess kind of makes sense. And as you were sort of saying, I think whether one sort of container can be multi-purpose or whether you really are needing different containers for all of the different jobs, probably plays a huge role in sort of like how easy or hard it is. Yeah, yeah, totally. It's one of these things that like the lines are a little blurry because I'm sure, I'm sure someone's going to email us saying, oh, you could do actually this, an airflow or, you know,
Ray 不是持久的。所以如果你的 Ray 作业，你知道，你需要负责进行检查点设置之类的。如果你的 Ray 作业中途挂了，它就没了。你拥有的任何检查点都是你自己创建的。你知道，其他那些工具，它们本质上一直在创建检查点。所以，是的，基本上有几件事你需要权衡。
Ray could also do that, but just generally speaking, like, at the baseline level, you know, Ray is not durable. So if your Ray job, you know, you're responsible for doing checkpointing and things like that, you know, if your Ray job dies halfway through, it's just gone. Whatever checkpoint you have is whatever you created. You know, these other ones, you know, they'll just by their nature, they're constantly creating checkpoints. And so, yeah, there's basically several things you're juggles.
你知道，你希望这些任务、这些工作流的部分有多持久，然后你的延迟要求是什么，以及你愿意花费的成本是多少？因为 Ray，你知道，对于每一个……举个例子，假设你有一种任务，该任务有一个 Python 第三方库列表，
you know, how durable do you want these tasks to be, these parts of your workflow, and then what's your latency requirement, and then what's your sort of cost you're willing to spend? Because Ray, you know, for every... So just to give an example, let's say you have some type of task, and that task has a list of Python third-party libraries
需要运行，需要包含在内。所以如果你使用 Airflow，当那个任务节点启动时，它会启动你的 Docker 容器，你已经在其中放入了那些库，对吧，它准备好了，它执行你的代码，这很好。使用 Ray，你创建一个带有这些依赖项的 Docker 容器，类似于 Airflow，但你启动了一个完整的集群，并且该集群上的每个节点都有所有这些 Python 依赖项。所以如果你有异构的任务，比如一个任务需要 Torch（这是一个 2GB 的 pip 文件），而另一个任务只是发送一封电子邮件（只需要基础 Ubuntu），那么 Airflow 在这里会为你节省一点。所以，是的，没有免费的午餐，有几件事需要权衡。所以一些建议，我认为 Ray 是……你应该只在延迟很重要时才使用 Ray。
that need to be run, need to be included. So if you do Airflow, you know, when that task node spins up, it spins up your Docker container where you've already put those libraries in it, right, and it's ready to go, and it executes your code, and that's fine. With Ray, you create a Docker container with those dependencies, similar to with Airflow, but you spin up an entire cluster, and every node on that cluster has all those Python dependencies. you know so if you have especially like heterogeneous things where maybe you have one task that requires torch which is like a two gigabyte pie pie file right and then you have another task that's just send an email you know that only requires like the base Ubuntu you know that an airflow is going to save you a little bit there so yeah there's no free lunch there's like several things to juggle I guess so some advice um I think Ray is, is, you should only use Ray if latency is important.
所以如果你在做机器学习训练，延迟非常重要。你有这个 GPU，它非常昂贵，你不想在上面浪费时间。这就是为什么 Ray 在训练这些 AI 模型方面非常受欢迎。如果你在做机器学习相关的事情，或者产生大量图表和工件的事情，我认为 Kubeflow 可能是一个不错的选择。对于其他所有事情，如果你的工作是 Python 编写的，我会使用 Dagster。否则，我会使用 Airflow。
So if you're doing ML training, latency is very important. You have this GPU, it's very expensive, you don't want to waste time on it. So that's why Ray is extremely popular for, uh, training these AI models. Um, if you're doing ML stuff or things where you're producing a lot of, um, you know, graphs and a lot of those artifacts, I think Q-Flow could be a good, choice. And for everything else, I would use Dagster if what you're doing is in Python. Otherwise, I would use Airflow.
所以这就是选择工作流编排器的工作流图。是的，他只是为我们开好了处方。我想这叫流程图。但是的，好的。哦，那是真的。酷。是的，我想，你知道，一些
So that's sort of the workflow diagram of which workflow orchestrator to pick. Yeah. Can he's just all prescribed out for us? I guess it's called a flow chart. But yeah, okay. Oh, that's true. Cool. Yeah, I guess, you know, some like,
除了自己构建编排器之外需要避免的事情是，我认为你可以走向另一个极端，用自动扩缩容和许多其他东西把事情搞得超级复杂。我认为你可以采取小步快跑的方式。
things to avoid other than rolling your own orchestrator is I think you can go the other direction and kind of make things super complicated with auto scaling and a lot of these other things. I think you can take baby steps
就像任何事情一样，你可能会开始深入研究，最后钻得太深，说“哦，我要用这些包预加载节点”，但归根结底，你知道，你希望这能为你节省时间。你不希望这些东西花费你大量时间。
with these things. Just like anything, you can kind of start getting into it and end up diving super, super deep and saying like, oh, I'm going to preload the nodes with these packages and at the end of the day, like you know, this, you want this to save you time. You don't want this stuff to cost you a lot of time.
有道理。谢谢你的概述。是的，教育意义。是的，这是一件值得学习的事情，伙计们。我认为这超级、超级有用。如果你正在寻找入门方法，想象一下你有一个网站，有任何需要完成的任务。我正在尝试找一个好的例子。比如，你有一个网站只是进行 OCR 图片识别。有人上传，把图片拖到你的网站上，你通过电子邮件给他们发回一些文本之类的。现在，OCR 速度快得惊人。
Makes sense. Thanks for the overview. Yeah. Yeah, the education. Yeah, this is a good thing to learn, folks. I think this is super, super useful. If you are looking to get started, imagine you have a, you have a website that has any type of job that needs to get done. I'm trying to have a good example. Like, you have a website that just OCR's pictures. Someone puts a upload, drags a picture into your website and you send them back some text or something in an email. And nowadays, OCR is so bloody fast.
你可以瞬间响应。但让我们假装我们还处于它需要很长时间的阶段。你知道，只要启动 Temporal。我认为它相对容易搭建。我想他们也有托管服务。价格非常合理。然后说，“看，我要调用这个函数来做 OCR，那个函数会做 OCR 并发送电子邮件，”
Like, you can just respond instantly. But let's pretend like we're still where that took a long time. You know, just spin up temporal. You know, it's, I think it's relatively easy to stand up. I think they have a managed service too. It's very reasonably priced. and say, look, like, I'm going to call this function to do the OCR, and that function is going to do the OCR and send the email,
“我只是把它包装在 Temporal 中，现在它是持久的了。”这可能是一个简单的入门方法。酷。好的。是的，我们希望你们喜欢这一集，一定要继续给我们发送对新内容、新节目想法的请求。我们非常认真地对待它们。
and I'm just going to wrap it in temporal, and now it's durable. And that could be just an easy way to get started. Cool. All right. Yeah, we hope you folks like the episode, and definitely keep sending us, you know, requests for new content, new show ideas. We take them super seriously.
我们已经实现了其中的许多。所以我们的列表越来越短了。所以如果你有节目主题，请在 Slack 或 Discord 上联系我们。我是说，发邮件给我们，无论你想通过什么方式联系。谢谢大家。由 Eric Barndollar 制作。《Programming Throwdown》根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，
we've implemented many of them. So our list is getting smaller. So if you have a show topic, please Slack us or Discord us. I mean, email us, however you want to reach out to them. Thank you, everyone. by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons attribution, share-alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和Patrick的贡献，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。